you feel the Panic making your
temperature rise like chili oil on the
tongue as you race down an Alleyway
narrowly avoiding the Carnage unfolding
all around you ducking behind a wall you
press your back against the brick hoping
that if you maybe just stay still you'll
avoid getting caught in the crossfire
War has come to the streets of the small
New York town but it is unlike any
conflict you could have ever imagined
the township of ago hasn't just been
turned into a war zone it's a cal Zone
staring at you on the opposite wall of
the alleyway are posters overlapping
posters all of the exact same
advertisements for the aglo hot slice
they're everywhere covering the whole
wall with scrawled lettering hand drawn
over each one that reads all hail Kevin
ago hot slice loves you join us eat eat
eat eat eat come be with us come be with
us we love you it's like a nightmare
that you can't wake up from everything
around you serving up a reminder that
you're in deep dish and any moment now
you'll be dead meat taking a deep breath
to steady yourself you grip your camera
in your trembling fingers removing the
lens cap and holding on tight as you
peer out from the alleyway to snap some
shots of the front lines the world needs
to know about this Mayhem all the lives
long lost and marinara spilled in a
senseless exchange of violence the lens
brings the moving shapes down the street
into Focus but you still can't believe
that they're real the soldiers of this
War aren't human not all of them at
least you distinctly remember seeing two
human combatants the leaders of these
Waring factions one of the foot soldiers
is clashing with an enemy a homunculus
almost in the vague shape of a person
facing off against a metallic Mass armed
with circular blades as your finger
presses the shutter you capture the
closing moments of their Fight The
homunculi Swinging a large formless arm
almost like it's made out of a lump of
clay missing hands and fingers of its
own trying to use brute strength against
its metal opponent the next shot shows
the metallic creature slicing through
the homunculus with deadly practiced
efficiency leaving nothing but a pile of
dough and cheese leaking thick goopy
marinara soft onto the asphalt you lower
your camera tears streaming down your
face as you look around and see scenes
like that unfolding all around you
they're fighting in every building on
every street corner the Thunder of
artillery strikes and explosions from
crashing drones are deafening war is
hell and now you've seen that for
yourself firsthand but while your
attention is fixated on the horrors of
bread and cheese-based warfare erupting
all around you you you don't notice a
hulking Pizza creature lumbering behind
you ready to strike Welcome to aglo New
York Ground Zero in a war unlike any
other a conflict that the SCP Foundation
has designated as SCP
4201 like any War it's important to know
who the key players are what the
inciting incidents were that triggered
it and what deep-seated ideological
differences are being fought over it's a
war between two pizza restaurants oh
really well that sure seems a little
Half Baked oh didn't like that one too
cheesy for
you in that case pop some lactose
tablets and grab a slice of the action
ready to understand exactly how and why
these two rival businesses turn to
enemies duking it out on the battlefield
do you remember the 23rd night of
September because that's when the
municipality of aglo New York welcomed a
brand new eery to its humble Township
their local paper The aglo Herald was on
the scene to report on the grand opening
of the aglo hot slice a new Pizzeria
established by local resident Kevin
Kerber now you might not think that the
opening of a new pizza place would be
all that newsworthy but for one not much
happens in aglo New York and for another
what made this a notable occurrence for
the locals was that the opening of the
aglo hot slice put the fledgling
Pizzeria in the crosshairs of a local
staple Mario's Pizza DEA
deloso history would come to know the
23rd night of September
1997 as the day the first shot was fired
in a war that would consume alow in
Flames like a wood burning oven for over
35 years Mario bian's traditional
Italian Pizzeria had been a local
fixture a homegrown icon bringing the
people of ago hand tossed dough that was
Woodfired to Perfection and served with
a smile but smiles turned to sour scows
as Kevin Kerber opened up the hot slice
many aglo residents feared that this
challenge to Mario's Pizza de deloso
would drive business away from the
longstanding local favorite but there
was a division of public opinions with
others glad for the arrival of the aglo
hot slice and the potential a new
Pizzeria had to break the Monopoly
Mario's hat on the localized market for
his own part the founder of the aglo hot
slice Kevin Kerber had no intentions of
musling in on Mr bian's Turf Kevin lived
in aglo for his entire life and had
plenty of fond memories of visiting
Marios to enjoy a slice with his friends
back when he was still in middle school
he was nothing but amicable towards the
local pizzeria owner and viewed the
opening of his hot slice as nothing more
than encouraging some healthy purely
professional comp competition between
the two of them it was Kevin's hope that
the competition would encourage both his
and Mario's businesses to maintain a
consistent quality of their food and in
a sense he was right the quality of both
their pizzas would certainly be put to
the test not just on the battlefield of
ago's Pizza Market but on the actual
Battlefield the town would soon become
to begin with there seemed to be little
animosity between Mario and Kevin's
competing pizzerias for both Mario Pizza
DEA deloso and aglo hot slice business
was booming while Mario had the skills
in many more years of experience he was
clearly not threatened by the existence
of his new rival yet over his more than
three decades in aglo Mario had
consistently put his other competitors
out of business thanks to the quality of
his pizza he even toppled the local
Pizza Hut Outlet so it was clear that he
didn't think there was much cause for
concern when the aglo hot slice opened
opened its doors Mr biion wasn't one to
cower from his Challenger either he made
a point of trying Kevin Kerber's Pizza
even complimenting it as the best pizza
Mario had ever tasted from a competitor
at least according to Mario in an
interview he gave with the aglo heral
hot slice had nothing on his own pizza
and even claimed that Kevin would have
to step up his game if he wanted a piece
of the local pizza pie well not exactly
an explosive retali a by Mario biani the
oven glove had certainly been thrown
down and the war to determine who had
the strongest pizza was on their War
wasn't initially one fought with guns
and bombs but their Primary Weapons in
their earliest battles were pizza and
advertising despite the widespread
Acclaim his pizza was earning Kevin
simply could not contend with the
longevity and positive reputation that
Mario's Pizza DEA delisio so held in
aglo he couldn't help that whenever
residents thought of pizza they
automatically thought of Marios after
all the garlic season veteran had put
five other competitors out of business
snuffing them out for good and leaving
him as the only Pizzeria standing in
aglo but Kevin was determined and
nowhere was that more apparent in his
aggressive marketing campaign for hot
slice the entire town seemed to be
covered in advertisements for Kevin's
Pizzeria touting the quality customers
could expect from eating there this
seemed to be doing the trick as within
its first week ago's hot slice saw
around 7,000 customers impressive
figures when you consider that the
town's population was only around 10,000
it was almost as if the entire town was
mesmerized by Kevin and his pizza one
advertisement featured in The aglo
Herald even included the quote it isn't
possible for pizza to be perfect
attributed to someone who's never tried
ago hot slice within the first month of
hot slice's opening things started to
take a turn for the strange although the
town of AGA wasn't exactly known for
being a hot bed of extreme weather the
night of October 3rd 1997 would have
been seen as unusual anywhere else a
freak thunderstorm rolled into ago
bringing with it a massive downpour of
rain the force of the storm was actually
so great that many locals found that
holes formed in their roofs but the
water come pouring in but that wasn't
even close to the strangest part about
the storm local meteorologists estimated
that there were over 700 individual
strikes of lightning that night with the
two most notable locations that were
affected being Mario's Pizza DEA deloso
and the ago hot slice the latter in
particular took a heavy beating during
the storm being struck by approximately
50 lightning bolts however it seemed
that Kevin had been preparing for the
weather despite how unusual it was for
the area almost as if he had been
expecting it he'd installed 20 lightning
rods on his property meaning the damage
was kept to a minimum as were the
effects of the storm on Marios which
remained relatively unscathed although
it certainly seemed as if the heavens
themselves had chosen a side in the
ongoing feud between the Rival pizzerias
the strange happenings didn't stop with
the freaks storm either later that same
month a pair of local teenagers
witnessed something that baffled them
both strange humanoid creatures in
Mario's Pizza deail yoso the aglo police
wrote their story off as nothing more
than teenage hooligan likely fueled by
illicit substant use but the two boys
Jeffrey aisel and Justin copper stood by
their story regardless of how
inexplicable it sounded while walking
around town late one night the two of
them noticed strange movements inside
the pizzeria what first caught their
attention was the lights were still on
well past 11:00 at night whereas Pizza
DEA dioso closes at 9: checking closer
the pair of teenagers tried the front
door only to find much to their surprise
that it was still unlocked stepping
inside Jeffrey and Justin saw Mario
biani sitting at one of the booths in
his own restaurant with pizza slices on
the table before him he began lighting C
handles and placing them around the
table while reciting a strange chant
that the boys found
incomprehensible but they continued to
watch as he ground up a red chalk-like
substance in his hands then blew the
resultant dust over the pizza slices
given what happened next it's safe to
assume he wasn't trying out a new type
of topping before the terrified and
Confused eyes of the two teens the pizza
formed an inum creature it sat up and
scanned the room quickly spotting the
pair of intruders Which con Aus a mouth
to form in its head slice the pizza
homunkulus screeched at Jeffrey and
Justin causing Mario to get up and start
yelling at them both to leave 2 Days
Later the strange reports surrounding
the Waring pizzerias continued to
circulate with even more ads for the hot
slice plastered all over town over the
course of what appeared to be a single
night every square foot of space in aglo
was plastered with new advertisements
there was no way that Kevin Kerber
acting alone could have played that many
posters and flyers for his Pizzeria in a
single night to make things even
stranger over 70% of the local residents
had visited the hot slice since the
advertisements were posted with many of
them not coming back out staff from the
agow heral attempted to investigate but
similarly didn't return making it
impossible for anyone to learn what was
truly going on inside then sometime
after this it happened tensions Rose
getting hotter like melting cheese until
war broke out SCP 4201 is the
designation given to the ensuing
conflict between Mario's Pizza DEA
deloso and the ago hot slice both
restaurants possess their own military
forces each deploying different weapons
and tactics that seem to be linked to
each different pizzeria's Aesthetics and
theme Mario's troops consisted of large
anomalously animated homunculi creatures
each one was made of out of various
Pizza ingredients including dough cheese
and various other toppings made to order
well to follow orders these forces were
divided into infantry and Cavalry with
their combat style highly similar to
that of the Napoleonic War era Mario's
foot soldiers were all armed with
bayonetted rifles while they were
supported by Cavalry units and artillery
their Commander himself rode into battle
on a construct that resembled a horse
however made out of the same ingredients
as the rest of his forces while leading
his military efforts Mario uses Pizza
based abilities to support his troops
apparently gain through the same unknown
anomalous means that he used to create
his army meanwhile the opposing forces
that serve under Kevin are mainly drones
and robots constructed around utensils
and appliances typically found in a
pizzeria like ovens or pizza Cutters
also acting as the general of his side
Kevin fights in a large suit of
mechanical armor with several Pizza the
themed weapons attached to it he also
utilizes more advanced Battle Tactics
and techniques including deploying his
drones with more modern Firearms as the
two Waring factions Battle For Stuff
crust Supremacy over aglo the SCP
Foundation has established a safe Zone
around the area evacuating any and all
civilians from the area once they
learned of the doughy disaster studying
the ongoing battle they have intercepted
radio communic Cas between Mario and
Kevin that shed light on their reasons
for continuing their Conflict for over
20 years in one recording Kevin lamented
the fact that they'd been fighting so
long and that there was no point in
continuing yet Mario refused to
surrender his rival argued that he
couldn't let the newcomer win and take
all of his customers despite Kevin
pointing out that their customers were
dead killed in the crossfire of the
pizza War the pair descended into an
argument with Mario calling Kevin out
for hypnotizing the town's folk into
eating at the hot slice and forcing them
to make his metallic Army while Kevin
rebutted citing how Mario murdered his
earlier competitors through the use of
black magic even with everyone in a 10m
radius dead Mario was still obsessed
with defending his Pizzeria he accused
Kevin of never having set foot in Pizza
DEA deloso and that he was nothing more
than a corporate shell with no care or
pride in making Cuisine for people to
this day the pizza war is still ongoing
and has been raging for much longer than
the advertised 30 minutes or less
working at the SCP Foundation can really
get your appetite going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in SCP 682s tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the devour of
worlds on the other side of SCP
2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is at the SCP
Foundation even the break room can be
perilous do Dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this presents
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
going to need your your food fast and
when it comes to fast food few eies are
as prolific as the golden arches
McDonald's and just to clarify this
video is not sponsored we're going to
tell you about a horrifying anomalous
secret that this company really doesn't
want you to know about let's not think
about that just yet though your stomach
is rumbling and you need that quarter
pounder so bad that even being trapped
in the red reality with Dr Scranton
couldn't stop you from getting it when
you finally arrive you buy your typical
order a quarter pounder with French
fries a coffee and a McFlurry you see Dr
clef a few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage as you sit and enjoy your
meager little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of SCP 173s Containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for McDonald's
Happy Meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it scares you
those big soulless eyes the wide gaping
ma full of two white teeth it's
diabolical sneakers no child should ever
have to look at that you can't help but
wonder whatever happened to Ronald
McDonald the hamburger happy clown that
Shield fast food to you throughout your
childhood what is he up to now well we
have an answer for you but I'll warn you
you may not be quite is eager to suck
down a Big Mac and a DI of coke after
hearing this Ronald McDonald first
introduced as the company's mascot in
1963 had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the
company in the mid-2010s for a greater
focus on the nasty little box homunculus
you can thank John Wayne gasy Pennywise
and those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor Stateside Ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the Ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in North
America a monster was born a horrific
Abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about SCP 058 the Heart
of Darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and Scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time
While most people would have screamed
run away or called the police the
farmers at this particular cattle farm
decided to let it ride and see how this
whole nightmarish Affair played out that
sense of curiosity and patience would
soon pay off for them financially it
didn't take long for the creature to
grow the bigger it got the more it
looked like a giant mutant version of
McDonald's iconic mascot Ronald McDonald
and this wasn't just a coincidence
either it turned out that this monster
was somehow intrin ically linked to the
McDonald's brand because once a day the
creature would horrifically unhinge its
jaw and begin to barf out a huge
quantity of McDonald's food and we're
not talking about raw materials that are
converted into McDonald's food the
creature later dubbed SCP
5962 vomited out fully packaged
McDonald's products the owners of this
clownish monster had just hit the
lottery so to speak while the
particulars of the deal are unclear they
somehow contacted a representative of of
the McDonald's corporation based in
China in exchange for presumably a large
sum of money Chinese McDonald's
operatives covertly entered the country
and shephered the now massive creature
over to a McDonald's owned Warehouse in
Beijing by this point it was around 4 M
tall and weighed over 5 tons it was kept
inside a cage and housed at some cost
but soon enough the creature was paying
for itself as we mentioned before the
creature constantly secreted fry oil
which was siphoned off for use in
preparing McDonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that it vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the Chinese branch of
McDonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course SCP 5962 had
become McDonald's China's best kept
secret but of course no secret this
Sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse house were paid or threatened
for their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around Beijing about a huge clown
inside of a McDonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the SCP Foundation finally
took notice two agents Jonathan Jang and
George nagasa were dispatched to perform
an infiltration Mission along with a
team of backup Personnel they entered
the warehouse apprehending any employees
they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility they found SCP 5962 with
a heavy collar around its neck chained
to the ground like King Kong as
McDonald's employees wielded away carts
of package food neither of the attending
agents were fans of McDonald's food but
even then just seeing this horrible
display was enough to make them feel
nauseous the the creature was taken and
contained by the SCP Foundation who
conducted a number of tests on it they
found that the monster had no real
internal organs saved for 27
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found that the creature was far
more cow than human the same could sadly
not be said for the food that SCP 5962
was vomiting out seriously if you were
already feeling a little queasy from all
this we need to warn you that this is
the part where things get really vile
let's talk about what the McDonald's
food barfed up by SCP P 5962 was
actually made out of as we mentioned
earlier the food exuded by the creature
was genetically human with DNA often
matching that of people who are alive
and in no way affected by this anomalous
process tests have indicated that
certain foods condiments and beverages
correspond to more specific types of
bodily tissue and liquid for example the
bacon and Fries were shown to be
cartilage and ligaments the bread turned
out to be made from hair nails and skin
the coffee was liquefied feal matter the
chicken nuggets were made from fingers
ovaries and testes even the water was a
mix of saline and sweat and of course
the ice cream was comprised of pus bone
marrow feces and nasal mucus depending
on the flavor you get the idea we'll
stop listing off examples before you
lose your lunch but rest assured all of
the food produced by SCP 5962 was made
of human organic matter when the SCP
Foundation interviewed Mr Chen the
manager of the facility where SCP 59 62
was being held before his amnestic
treatment he seemed incredibly casual
about the whole thing as far as he was
concerned the food still tasted exactly
the same as regular McDonald's food and
it didn't appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could
expect from regular non-anomalous fast
food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughter houses
where the meat is typically obtained Mr
Chen also contested that SCP 5962 wasn't
all that dangerous either the only time
it ever performed an offensive action
was when an employee of the enemy fast
food franchise Burger King entered its
vicinity the creature vomited a stream
of hot coffee at the corporate
interloper like a fire hose until he
left suggesting that it does have some
kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonald's company but still other than
this isolated incident the creature has
never even displayed sentience it was a
big strange clownish McDonald's food
dispenser when questioned about the
origins of SCP
5962 Mr Chen once again underplayed the
strange of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
SC SCP 5962 had also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the US the farm which we can only assume
is situated right next to a radioactive
waste dump was also behind SCP
4158 also known as Big Charlie this
giant omnivorous and seemingly Immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been
birthed from a non-anomalous cow sold to
the Butcher Block slaughterhouse it
looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues leading
to the employees at the slaughterhouse
trying to put the creature out of its
misery however no matter how hard they
tried to kill the monster it just
wouldn't die its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually The
Slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
nonanomalous meat much like the Chinese
McDonald's and SCP
5962 the workers had just hit the
lottery with big Charlie as long as they
kept feeding the monster which ate
everything from bricks to other
non-anomalous cows it provided a pretty
much Limitless supply of meat giving
them unprecedented economic prosperity
in other words big Charlie was a literal
Cash Cow Jeff fine the slaughterhouse
director even started worshiping big
Charlie as a kind of demigod by drinking
his blood he believed that big Charlie
was a savior sent to lift them all out
of their struggle and Desperation sadly
for them the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when big Charlie escaped
their slaughterhouse and Foundation
field agents found secured and contained
it it was a sad day for the Butcher
Block so what have we learned today
whether you're in the US OFA or the
Chinese Heartland if you're chowing down
on fast food you really have no idea
where it came from I mean we kind of
knew that already but for all we know
the the food you're enjoying could have
just been vomited up by a giant fat
clown or cut from the Flesh of a mutated
cow just think about that next time
you're enjoying a burger but hey let's
be honest with ourselves we'll all
probably still eat it feeling hungry
maybe you could go for a snack right
about now or a nice refreshing can of
your favorite soda perhaps if you've got
some change burning a hole in your
pocket a nearby vending machine would be
a good choice and trust us there's no
vending machine like this this one SCP
261 will give you a treat that's out of
this world or rather out of this
Dimension that's how this safe class
anomaly earned its incredibly accurate
name the interdimensional vending
machine it was first discovered in a
dark alley in Yokohama Japan Japan is a
place where you can find a number of
strange and surprising things in vending
machines but nothing quite like this the
foundation was first alerted to its
presence after one of their web TRS
noticed some interesting chatter on
Japanese online message boards about a
magic vending machine to these Japanese
Forum users it sounded like a fanciful
urban legend a vending machine where you
could get something truly Fantastical if
you have the yen to spare but upon
thorough investigation field agents of
the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no Legend and brought it
into containment it's the kind of thing
you wouldn't look twice at an utterly
generic black vending machine with no
viewing window and a handwritten sign in
Japanese that reads out of order but
what the vending machine looks like
isn't nearly as interesting as what it's
capable of when you insert your money
into the machine and it's important to
note that it only accepts Japanese Yen
the machine will dispense some kind of
snack food or drink item however over
time the more the machine is used in a
single day the more bizarre the items it
spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out
how the machine works but their task has
been incredibly difficult so far it
doesn't appear to contain any snacks and
it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is opened or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become stranger much faster but let's
be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
SCP 261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension bone appeti let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
Pepsi Co does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
opened which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with A Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not everybody
likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick a
rebel only a soft drink with a formal
title can quench your thirst and as such
you prefer Dr Pepper in which case maybe
the vending machine will furnish you
with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing
straw this spatial anomaly wrapped
inside a Whimsical Dr Pepper branded
straw seems to contain far more liquid
than should be able to fit in the straw
about 1 bottles worth of soda to be
precise a nice and convenient solution
for whenever you need to get the fix
that only an accredited doctor of
popology can provide and if you fancy
something from the more intoxicating end
of the beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen you
can get yourself a rare bottle of Billy
beer it's just the thing for those who
weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I had
this beer brewed just for me I think
it's the the best I've ever tasted and
I've tasted a lot I think you'd like it
too Billy Carter drinking the beer got a
declass intoxicated for 72 hours but
what if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully SCP 261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery Seven Grain
this small aluminum tube lets you
squeeze out a blob of dough which
instantly Rises and Cooks itself into a
tasty little loaf of bread testing is
indicated that the bread is a little
chewy but still tastes completely fine
not bad for a tubed baked good how about
some seafood to go with that bread then
maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of lemon clams and we
do mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine once put out
the laay blooming onion while it appears
to be a normal onion each layer of the
onion is a different flavor of Chip
leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and and mem worthy
well you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you're wearing
it though this could be a dangerous
anomalous effect if you decide to walk
through your local dog park while you're
wearing it we've been told it pairs well
with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 Trilby style Fedora made entirely out
of Teriyaki flavor beef jerky the object
came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline you can have your
hat and eat it too which is a pun that
probably makes a lot more sense in their
Dimension still a bit hungry well lucky
for you this magical vending machine has
got you covered on dessert too for 700
Yen the foundation was given an entire
edible chest set with each of the ornate
pieces carve from what seemed like hard
Pez Style candy it's less checkm made
and more check eight another pun that I
promise is funnier in another dimension
and for 300 Yen extra you might walk
away with a candy robot playet these are
more hard candy components that can be
put together to create functional
anomalous mini robots that move on their
own walking aimlessly and bumping into
walls but what about the full meal
craving consumer on the go who wants
both a dinner and a dessert combined
into one disgusting package don't worry
the interdimensional vending machine has
got you covered Just 4 100 yen can net
you some delicious turdo chaken these
are balls of fried turkey filled with
chocolate a smaller ball of duck more
chocolate and in the very center a small
ball of fried chicken even the labeling
on the product describes it as having
450% of an adult human's daily
recommended fat intake we'll leave it to
you to decide if this is a decadent
treat worthy of the gods or utterly
disgusting maybe you're feeling a little
cheeky though or you need the perfect
comedic dessert for your bachelorette
party the vending machine has a candy
direct from an alternate Korea a tasty
if slightly too sweet chocolate candy
shaped like a certain male organ filled
with we kid you not liquid white
chocolate perfect for anyone who has
both the sweet tooth and the sense of
humor of a 12-year-old okay these were
definitely all weird Treats but let's
get really really strange now from the
disgusting to the confusing to the
inedible to the straight up deadly if
you're a bit of a stist perhaps you're
the kind of person who enjoys watching
their snacks dying in front of them
before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box
with a viewing window and a red button
on top inside are a collection of small
furry creatures each with a single big
eye when the button is pressed the
creatures inside are abruptly
superheated cooking them all to death at
that point the Box opens and the cre
creaters are ready to eat we've been
told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef maybe you're part of
the slow food movement for that we
recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amounts of vitamin C
E and most of the the B complex which
are all crucial to a healthy and
balanced diet the disadvantage is that
they contain large amounts of arsenic
which will kill you though of course if
you still have a candy flavored death
wish but you prefer your entomological
treats a little more leggy then may we
interest you in a fine caramelized
spider for a modest 500 yen it's full of
deadly quantities of an unknown aness
Venom that's pretty much impossible to
cure but it's worth it for the Sweet
Sticky goodness that comes before death
sets in another strange item dispensed
by the vending machine was a tall metal
aluminum canister with a ring pole that
upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a
large explosion apparently this
particular beverage was never intended
for oxygenated environments the blast
killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing
though in a slight silver lining for
this Fiasco the testing area did smell
of citrus for a few days which the the
janitors must have enjoyed as they
cleaned up all the body parts another
dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of chips called
prangles not to be confused with any
other long tube base chips you may be
thinking of when the tube was opened or
popped as they say the d-class that the
chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when
researchers ordered the d-class to stop
it seemed almost as if they couldn't
regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when
guards terminated the declass there and
then the corpse continued to eat chips
out of the tube until it was physically
Pride out of their hands but if all
those salty prangles had really worked
up a thirst in you perhaps you can wash
them down with a delicious can of Cherry
Bomb an intense cherry flavored drink
dispensed by SCP 261 for 450 Yen when a
declass sampled this delicious soda they
commented on it tasting strongly of
cherry a few moments later later their
head exploded with the force of a stick
of dynamite coating everyone and
everything around it in gooey head
visera the resulting cleanup took an
arduous 6 hours but wow was that cherry
tasty and finally why not complete this
anomalous vending machine Feast with a
1,000 yen papier-mâché pinata resembling
a dead horse that comes ready to use
with a baseball bat everyone who saw the
pinata fell compelled to beat it
mercilessly with the bat until candy
began to fall out many in attendance
claimed that it was the 1,000th gift
Unleashed by SCP 261 and thus warranted
celebration once the dead horse was
thoroughly beaten all Cognito hazardous
properties ceased there's a joke
somewhere in there but for the life of
us we're not sure we can find it oh well
maybe it's in another dimension think
back to your childhood and ask yourself
what was the most pain you've ever felt
while growing up as we develop our
understanding of pain evolves according
to our different experiences the older
we get the injuries we suffered as
children like a scraped knee or a bee
sting rarely caus us the same level of
distress as they used to of course when
you are young and unfamiliar with
sensations of pain what you really need
in that moment straight after you've
fallen off your bike or tripped playing
soccer is someone to pick you back up
and give your Source spot a kiss perhaps
you even need a bowl of warm soup to
comfort you luckily for you SCP 348 is
exactly that while many of the anomalies
held in containment by the SCP
Foundation have earned the uid or
inFAMOUS ker class designations SCP 348
is one of the few considered to be safe
both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldrich Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through mimic stimuli nor is it a
recording of a basketall bball game in
which all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
SCP 348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look
indistinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course SCP 348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates SC SCP 348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is its anomalous
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it SCP 348 cannot
bend or reshaped reality it does not
cause the person eating from it to have
premonitions of their own death and
using it certainly does not manifest a
contract making entity at the opposite
side of the table so what makes this
bowl in any way anomalous what about it
categorizes it as an SCP and not just a
harmless piece of fine Crockery well why
don't we start with how SCP 348 was
first discovered some time ago the SCP
Foundation was made aware of rumors
surrounding the child living in an
unknown part of the world according to
the intelligence gathered by the
foundation this child seemed to possess
some sort of he heing ability or at
least this is what rumors suggested upon
further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as SCP 348 this is not to
say that the bowl has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SC CP Foundation recovered SCP 348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand painted around both the inside and
outside of SCP 348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters Shang
shini which translates to the phrase
thinking of you the child that first
discovered it found the ceramic Bowl in
the Attic of their home the child's
parents were both full-time workers and
seemed to be somewhat neglectful of
their child although they refused to
comment on this but according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation the child
had come to rely on SCP 348 deciding to
further investigate the anomalous
properties of SCP 348 the foundation
began testing it given that the child
who first discovered the bull had relied
upon it tests involve Foundation
researchers presenting certain children
to SCP 348 and observing the results so
was this bowl haunted perhaps harboring
some malicious Spirit or entity that
sought to corrupt these children maybe
even healing them in order to somehow
use them as a vessel to break into our
world no and while may have not healed
in any overt or expected way it did heal
in at least a metaphorical sense if
presented with an injured child sporting
any form of minor ailment such as a cut
or a running nose SCP 348 fills with
warm soup and yes that's right we said
soup what kind you may ask well that
seems to vary sometimes it is tomato
soup other times it might be chicken
noodle soup while the ingredients used
in the soups are often different there
are notable consistencies to how SCP 348
heels if anyone between the ages of 4
years old and 18 years old sits down in
front of the blue flowered Bowl then SCP
348 will fill with soup numerous young
test subjects brought in by the
foundation to eat from this particular
bowl of soup have reported that they
enjoyed their meal usually finishing the
entire Bowl when permitted to by
research staff many of the injured
children that were tested have stated
that the soup they eat from SCP 348
reminds them of their parents' cooking
these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claimed that even
though they were in a room all alone
they didn't feel lonely when they were
eating the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on SCP 348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of SCP 348 saw little girl
age8 and suffering from a sore throat
brought before the bowl according to a
background screening made by research
Personnel the girl lived with her
biological parents and apparently had a
good relationship with both her mother
and her father when SCP 348 filled with
soup for her the girl took almost half
an hour to finish eating and afterwards
reported that she felt her sore Roo get
better as she ain't by the end of the
meal this test subject remarked that she
felt completely normal in this instance
no message appeared within the bowl
another child was brought in to continue
the testing of SCP 348 this time a boy
of 10 unlike the previous test this boy
was not on good terms with his parents
and often argued with them at the time
of testing the boy had sustained several
minor bruises the result of a small
accident that occurred while the boy had
been out riding his bik like much like
the little girl this subject ate the
soup that SCP 348 presented him with
this time though the bowl offered a
message to the boy the lettering found
on the ceramic surface of SCP 348 simply
read don't forget to brush messages also
appeared when an 11-year-old boy with a
slight cold ate soup from the bowl this
child had been adopted by a foster
family and after eating from SCP 348 he
saw the message I'm glad you're happy
appear another young test subject a boy
age six had a similar experience in this
instance the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his
friends his parents had divorced and he
was living with his mother at the time
of testing this time SCP 348 message to
this boy read I'm sorry son a 7-year-old
girl suffering from a cough was brought
in before SCP 348 she had lost her
father to a traffic accident some time
before testing commenced and received
the the message I love you after
finishing her soup further testing
conducted by the foundation revealed
that anyone over the age of 18 years who
attempted to eat soup from SCP 348
experienced things slightly differently
unlike the children older subjects
mostly displayed a disinterest in
finishing their meal a common complaint
among those over 18 was that the soup
was missing something however in a few
isolated cases testing SCP 348 on older
candidates still revealed messages
although the words seemed to be faded
not the clear hand painted blue that
appeared when the children had finished
their soup one woman aged 30 who was
suffering from a headache sat down in
front of SCP 348 much like it had done
before the bowl filled with soup and the
woman at as with some of the younger
subjects a key aspect of This Woman's
background seemed to be what triggered
the message to appear specifically she
admitted to being on bad terms with her
mother and father the woman explained
that she had opted to live on her own
isolating herself from her family in
fact she even described having rejected
an offer her father made to her many
years earlier refusing some Career
Training that he was willing to give in
order to help her secure a job when she
finished the soup one word appeared in
the bowl why another woman who was 40
years old was also brought in for the
SCP 348 testing much like the previous
subject she had moved away from home and
became arrange from her parents over the
years but unlike the pre previous test
this woman had taken it upon herself to
not only send money to her parents but
also arranged senior care for both as
well prior to testing her father had
died peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared with an SCP 348 one other
adult subject subject that produced a
noticeable result from SCP 348 was a
40-year-old male the results of this
test appeared to be the most distinctly
different from any previous adult or
Child by now researchers working for the
SCP Foundation had determined that
familial history seemed to play an
important role in the outcome of any
interaction with SCP 348 and this
individual was certainly different to
most the man in question had murdered
his father roughly a year before the
testing took place he began the test
with SCP 348 while Afflicted with aches
in his back after one Taste of the soup
that appeared in the Bowl before him the
murderer was immediately repulsed he
complained about the taste refusing to
eat any more from SCP 348 shortly after
the man began to experience severe
stomach pain the potentially poisonous
soup was disposed of but SCP 348
immediately filled with saltwater which
took 3 hours to disappear from the bowl
despite conducting numerous nous tests
with subjects of all ages and ailments
the SCP Foundation researchers have so
far been unable to determine the origins
of the messages that sometimes appear in
SCP 348 some are theorize because of the
family histories of some children and
adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
reason researchers claim that this is
just the purpose of SCP 348 to provide
Comfort to small children dealing with
pain both inside and out after all isn't
providing Comfort what a good bowl of
soup anomalous or not is best at for a
moment we want you to cast your mind
back to your childhood a time when you
weren't as busy or burdened with the
pressures of life that come as you grow
up when you were carefree and had your
whole life ahead of you nothing but
potential and opportunity a simpler time
when the highest award you could achieve
wasn't a grade or a promotion but
something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of
the refrigerator oh to be a kid again
right then again maybe returning to
younger days is better left as a fantasy
it's hard to imagine that something so
pure so simple and wholesome as a
drawing on the fridge could ever be
something dark horrific even but then
you learn about SCP 683 and all of a
sudden returning to your childhood
becomes something you hope never happens
SCP 683 is an anomaly with various parts
to it so we'll start with SCP
683-1331 for everyone else picture the
refrigerator that Indiana Jones hid
inside to miraculously survive a nuclear
blast in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
that was such a plot device I don't know
about you guys but I'm feeling nervous
already like we said at first glance
you'd struggled to spot anything out of
the ordinary about this particular
fridge apart from maybe some slight wear
and tear on the Outside Inside though
it's perfectly clean kept in perfect
working condition for keeping food cool
but that that's the first weird thing
about SCP
683-1600 one's anomalous properties the
next is the the fact that the power cord
of this refrigerator ends with a plug
that doesn't match any known type of
wall outlet seems even stranger after
all who would design a fridge that can't
even be plugged in right in fact the SCP
Foundation had to design their very own
completely one-of-a kind adapter to
connect SCP 6831 to an ordinary gas
powerered home generator once plugged in
though SCP 6831 functions exactly like
you would expect any other refrigerator
to sort of it's about time we move on to
SCP 683 second component designated as
SCP
subject of this child's drawing is
pretty mundane just some scribbles of a
pleasant mountainous landscape a house a
well a dog a figure wearing a chef's TK
and of course an anthropomorphic son
with a smiley face now sure that might
not sound all that impressive but we
would advise you not to say anything
like that out loud criticizing the
drawing is a comment you might wish you
hadn't made just like when you fill our
comment sections with dated Among Us
memes seriously it's getting old any
person that makes any kind of negative
or disparaging remark about the SCP
68326 a31 will suffer a grim horrific
fate the next time they try to eat
anything this person will suffer immense
irreparable damage to their internal
organs along with their skin and muscle
tissue this is intensely painful causing
the subject agonizing pain as their
organs and skin are melted down the
amount the person loses is equal to the
mass of food they've eaten with each
bite they will lose more and more of
their body the painful process will not
stop until they have ingested 42 kg of
food making this even worse the process
doesn't seem to Target any organs that
would kill the subject immediately
they're made to suffer an excruciating
pain punished with torture for daring to
try and remove the drawing from the
fridge any and all subjects will die
within 26 days of taking that final bite
and thus losing the last piece of
themselves but where do the body parts
of these people go surely they don't
disappear you must be thinking and you
would be right in instances like this
the third mystery component of SCP 683
is revealed referred to as SCP 683 D3 a
brown paper lunch bag will manifest
inside the SCP 6831 fridge containing a
grim and grizzly assortment of meals on
every occasion the bag contains a
sandwich with a pretty disgusting
filling the Flesh and viscera of the
last person who dared to criticize the
drawing on the refrigerator there is
also a plastic Ziploc bag in which
you'll find the other half of the stolen
organs and flesh of this unlucky person
along with three chocolate chip cookies
surprisingly these are actually
completely normal cookies with no traces
of DNA or other abnormalities to them
every time there is also one final item
that forms the contents of SCP
6833 and that's a note which reads be a
good boy today this note Bears the same
handwriting as appears on the outer
surface of the paper bag upon which a
single name is written Eric now for
those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the SCP Foundation
that particular unassuming name might
sound very familiar it was the same name
mentioned by another anomaly known as
SCP
066 a brief bit of context for you SCP
066 was a living ball of yarn that
displayed friendly Behavior towards
Foundation staff however during an
experiment a thread was cut from SCP 0
66's body this caused the yarn to
transform into a ball of meat with a
pair of functional eyes protruding from
it as SCP 066 became hostile constantly
asking for an Eric whenever someone gets
too close to it the same name Eric was
also found carved into the back of scp1
168 another anomaly encountered by the
SCP Foundation SCP 168 was an anomalous
calculator which actually possessed some
level of sentience and had the ability
to communicate so who is Eric well
theories range far and wide but there's
no real definitive answer as to exactly
who or what Eric might B some claim he's
a reality bending entity others posit
he's an SCP that the foundation just
doesn't know about yet regardless he's
connected to some intriguing entities a
sentient calculator a formerly friendly
ball of yarn and a fridge with a child's
drawing on it that can steal people's
organs and put them in a lunch bag
especially for him it would seem that
Eric is a child maybe a school boy
possibly even the one responsible for
the drawing on SCP 68 83 this child
could even potentially be anomalous in
nature of course this is all just
rampant speculation on our part so it's
probably best to take all of that with a
grain of salt as we've said before it is
just a theory an SCP explained Theory
Eric might just remain one of the
foundation's many unanswered mysteries
for years to come but if that answer
doesn't satisfy you then why don't we go
back to SCP 683 maybe some something in
the frid's origin will give us a further
clue to the mystery of who Eric is the
fridge was first discovered by the SCP
Foundation in the storage unit of a
Washington Home owned by a woman named
Yolanda as coincidence would have it
Yolanda was a collector of vintage Home
Furnishings including refrigerators
which would probably explain why she
didn't think to throw out such an old
model of fridge from the
1950s according to her she found SCP 683
simply left on a nearby street corner
with nobody around that could have left
it there or anyone that could have
possibly been transporting it to the
local dump to give her a hand moving the
fridge Yolanda Enlisted the help of her
nephew who agreed to step in and assist
her in getting SCP 683 back to her house
unfortunately though the nephew passed
away only 2 weeks later apparently due
to Medical complications that came as
the result of a hernia according to his
death certificate could Yolanda's nephew
have been the mysterious and elusive of
Eric could something have happened to
him after his death that allowed him to
become some kind of anomaly who's to say
we can only guess and hope that one day
we might get a full answer as to why
Yolanda never suffered the effects of
SCP 683 she never actually tried to take
the SCP
reminded her of her nephew it would have
been a futile and foolish idea for
Yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate as any who try will
suffer that painful and horrifying
process of losing their organs and
having them appear in Eric's paper
lunchbag even fire can't remove the
drawing from the fridge at least not
permanently suggesting that even the
paper it is drawn on has its own
anomalous properties on three separate
occasions the SCP Foundation has it
attempted to test this setting SCP 6832
on fire with nothing more than a match
every time the drawing was incinerated
burning to ashes until there was nothing
left but within 68 hours SCP
[Music]
68326 3 a similar thing happens if
multiple people attempt to remove SCP
683-2382 suffer an anomalous lack of
organs when they next eat something so
you must be thinking that the way to
avoid that is to simply not eat to fast
and not ingest a single meal and yes
you'd be right that does saave off the
anomalous effects of the fridge and the
drawing but also means you're heading
towards an even slower painful death
from starvation to date two different
Foundation test subjects have died this
way by refusing to eat after interacting
with SCP 683 true the SCP Foundation is
most likely sitting on a whole calvacade
of different anomalies that can keep a
person alive without the need for food
but you know what they're like right the
foundation's hardly likely to share the
keys to surviving without having to eat
and there you have it folks that's SCP
683 don't worry it's highly unlikely
that you'll ever encounter it the
foundation keeps it under lock and key
in a Cell fitted with a steel door and
reinforced hinges SC CP 683 remains
covered in a large cloth to prevent any
members of personnel from looking at it
when the fridge isn't being used for
research or experiments but you have to
wonder what if it's not the only fridge
with these anomalous properties after
all it's rare for a manufacturer to make
just a single refrigerator of a certain
model maybe you'd better be wearing next
time you visit someone with an older
model of fridge in their kitchen and
just to be safe if there is a drawing
pin to the front door leave it where it
is an SCP Foundation researcher sits at
a table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the SCP you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of Flesh sizzling
and Searing from high heat he braces
himself self as a burst of heat hits the
back of his head as if a fireball has
erupted an object floats through the air
and settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the SCP
Foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for Humanity as
SCP
682 or the world-ending threat posed by
the likes of SCP
23177 some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with SCP 5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this quasi
humanoid meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features is held in an
airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation Personnel on a bi-weekly
basis SCP 5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with SCP 531 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise avoiding being eaten is hard
enough with creatures that can actually
be seen But like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained
SCP 55031 has developed an almost
perfect defense mechanism which is when
observed it will literally cease to
exist some might choose to refer to this
as a Quantum lock however it is worth
noting that traces left by SCP 531 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by SCP 5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does
not naturally this makes both avoiding
the creature and capturing it using
cameras difficult however when SCP 531s
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creatures
physical traits based on its silhouette
it has been deduced that SCP 5031
levitates about half a meter above
ground level Sports an abnormally small
necklace head a top and elongated torso
approximately 1.9 M long with three sets
of spinley lower arms that Branch
outwards using these arms and its
Loosely hanging body SCP 531 will lower
itself to hunt any human or animal that
draws near to it and uses the blade
likee tail to cut up
food perhaps the most interesting facet
of SCP 55031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
huxel appalled by the condition that the
creature was being kept in hux took over
the role of HCL supervisor for SCP 5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huble devised a
series of tests to introduce SCP 531 to
various different stimuli as a way to
better understand the creature and
hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering it's worth remembering that
the SCP Foundation makes its to be cold
not cruel in performing their duties to
protect normality and many of the
researchers and staff are just as
capable of having empathy for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a
shelter the first of huxtable's tests
involved installing speakers an SCP
55031 cell through which a variety of
different ambient and popular pieces of
music were played to see if they had any
effect on reducing the creature's stress
by judging SCP 5031 stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to
normal Huxtable was able to determine
how to best use music to calm the
creature SCP 531 seemed to convey higher
levels of stress when listening to
morning Forest deep Grotto and seaside
Paradise ambients as well as the best of
late 60s British rock band Jeth rotol
however the best of Mozart Ena kiss and
Ben Folds produced dramatically
different results decreasing SCP 531s
apparent stress following this test
senior researcher hux compiled a
playlist featuring SCP 531s favorite
music over time the stress reducing
effects of Music on SCP 531 seemed to
decrease but keeping the playlist on
shuffle seemed to keep the creature
consistently calmer than it had been
previously the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into SCP
5031 enclosure to monitor its reactions
and how its stress levels were affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure SCP 531 immediately Ely sliced
the ball in two with its tail in one
swift motion a similar result occurred
when researchers threw the creature a
basketball which was quickly punctured
and sliced open by SCP 50 31's tail its
stress levels first seemed to diminish
when the creature was offered a bowling
ball which it rolled around the
enclosure and then later knocked it
against a second bowling ball however
when one of the balls chipped rendering
it unable to roll properly SCP 531
stress increased dramatically until a
placement was offered researcher huxel
noted that SCP 55031 seemed to possess a
similar level of motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to
match next when given the choice between
two food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure SCP 55031 seemed to gravitate
towards higher quality food most notably
favored cooked rotisserie chickens over
animal carcasses it even chose this
option over a live chicken using its
tail to cut cut its food into more
manageable bite-sized portions rather
than ripping its meat with its hands or
teeth like many of its fellow
scps researcher huxel recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though SCP 55031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive providing the creature
with food of a better quality marginally
reduced its
stress senior researcher huxel next
attempted to test SCP 531s coexistence
with other living
subjects each time making sure that the
creature had been adequately fed to
avoid any unseemly
incidents first a life chicken was
introduced SCP 531 rolled its bowling
ball at high speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken's
stress levels and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the
process when a second chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 gently rolled a
basketball towards it but ceased any
further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball next
to be introduced in into the enclosure
was a blindfolded d-class staff member
who was instructed to sit down and roll
the basketball towards SCP 55031 after
doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to Cease the creatures
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxel had another class D engage in a
game of catch with SCP 5031 while facing
away from the
creature this test proceeded
successfully and Senior researcher huxel
remarked how SCP 55031 motor skills were
improving albeit gradually and with some
gentle encouragement through huxtable's
tests the creature was learning the next
test focused on teaching SCP 531
linguistic symbols utilized LCD displays
and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing SCP 531 was quickly able to
understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense
a rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image SCP 531 was able to
determine which station dispense chicken
through a process of elimination
whenever the functions and displays were
swapped SC p531 would find whichever
displayed the word chicken to receive
its food the Final Phase of this test
presented SCP 55031 with a single
station displaying the word chicken but
with a button that would remain inactive
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed SCP 5031 was able to
assemble the word correctly not only
activate ating the button and dispensing
food but proving to researcher huxel
that the creature was capable of
learning language huxel continued to
test the creature encouraging it to
spell words using lettered blocks as a
method of communicating by increasing
SCP 50 31's vocabulary and the amount of
human interaction it received senior
researcher huxel observed that SCP 531
was gradually learning to sing albeit
non-verbally as well as to juggle with
its six hands and was even communicating
its food preferences and Dish
pairings later another class D D 52125
was introduced to SCP 531s enclosure to
Aid in further testing through d521 25's
instructions the creature quickly
learned to draw using crayons and
created artworks depicting itself its
Newfound friend d521 125 researcher
Huxtable a cat and a rotisserie
chicken SCP 5031 new creative s didn't
stop there though as the creature
quickly learned to play chopsticks in
only 2 days once a piano was introduced
into the enclosure SCP 55031 even
managed to start creating its own
original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d521 125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be SCP 531s new favorite
hobby as it spent the next 3 days
experimenting with different
combinations of foods and es using
its letter blocks to request more more
more garlic powder interestingly the
creature only created artwork or music
when D 52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone following this
development senior researcher huxel
devised a new test for SCP 531 providing
the creature with cooking utensils and
using D 52125 to demonstrate 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of
different dishes from hamburgers and
Tacos to Mongolian beef steak clam
chowder and peritols in addition to a
small peanut allergy this eighth test
revealed SCP 55031 to be a phenomenal
Chef possessing culinary skills far
beyond the average person the creature
quickly and enthusiastically embraced
its Newfound talents concocting its very
own brand new recipes with d 52125 even
volunteering to be the first to taste
test 31's dishes it was shortly after
this test that SCP 55031 spoke its very
first word and it should come as no
surprise that the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxel was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development the final
test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for over the course of
2 months SCP 531 was tasked with
creating a full three course meal which
would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving SCP 531 not only Rose
to the task but exceeded all of
researcher huxtable's expectations
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsey
would be hard pressed to find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck coni glazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compost paired with
a sight of butternut squash noi and
served on a bed of kalees seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a spiced cassava pie
for dessert complimented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup and SCP 5031 didn't stop
there the creature also debuted one of
its original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
SCP 5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxel but the
entire Foundation staff as a fitting end
to the creature's tail huxel reported
that during the Thanksgiving banquet it
had created SCP 5031 stress levels
reduced
entirely new Kinder containment measures
that would keep 5031 safer but also far
more contented were submitted for
approval perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that SCP 5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world instead SCP 55031 is a gentle if a
little frightening at first creature
that just requires careful and
considered guidance instead of a cold
iron cage and around the-clock armguards
through testing senior researchers
Stanley huxel and his fellow Foundation
staff were not only able to help the
creature develop but also found what
makes it tick and not just for the
purposes of containing it instead it is
hoped that SCP 531s creativity and flare
for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow under
the proud watch of researcher huxel Dr
blast and his group of researchers stand
behind bulletproof viewing glass they
all have very serious looks on their
face that is until the first test begins
on one side of the test room a Class D
subject stands holding a sheet of paper
on the other side sits a bright red
tomato on a wooden table Dr blast pushes
the intercom button and speaks into the
microphone all right you may begin
d541 nods and looks down at the sheet of
paper in his hand he begins to read is a
hippopotamus a hippopotamus or really
just a cool opotamus nothing happens
d541 stands there awkwardly waiting a
man next to Dr blast in the observation
room Snickers Dr blast jerks his head
toward the researcher and stares him
down this is not a laughing matter blast
says the reprimanded researcher clears
his throat and stands up straight sorry
sir Dr blast leans over and pushes the
microphone button again proceed to the
next joke d541 the man on the other side
of the glass nods and pulls a second
sheet of paper out from behind the first
what's an archaeologist someone whose
career is in Ruins says d541 a moment
after he finishes the joke The Ripe Red
Tomato launches itself off the table and
flies toward the face of d541 the tomato
is clocked at moving 104 mph d541 has no
time to move move before the Tomato
slams into his nose instantly breaking
it the men in the observation room
behind the bulletproof glass do their
best to hold back their laughter Dr
blast grumbles as he jots down notes on
his clipboard it appears that SCP 504 is
a certain taste in jokes he says to the
rest of the researchers in the room this
elicits a slight chuckle this might
indicate sapience I hope not clear the
room and bring in the next subject
medical personnel and a team of
custodial staff enter the room the
Physicians tend to d504 1's know and
carry him out the custodians clean the
remnants of the Tomato off the floor
walls and ceiling they exit leaving the
room completely empty a moment later the
door opens and another ordinary looking
tomato is brought in and placed on the
desk the SCP agent who brought in the
tomato leaves d504 2 enters the room a
moment later with a sheet of paper in
his hand he stands on the far side of
the room away from the SCP 504 tomato
sitting on the table he nervously brings
the paper close to his face to read
what's on it three tomatoes are walking
down the street d504 2 says with a
little Shake in his voice he had seen
d541 exit the room just before he
entered with blood and tomato paste
running down his face a papa tomato a
mama tomato and a little baby tomato
baby tomato starts laging behind POA
tomato gets very angry goes over to the
baby tomato and smooshes him and says
ketchup the new SCP 504 tomato
immediately goes flying from the table
straight toward the joke teller this
time the tomato is clocked at 260 6 4
mph when it slams into the face of
d542 the impact immediately renders him
unconscious after the first few trials
Dr blast decides that it's time to take
things up a notch the foundation has
collected hundreds of SCP 504 tomatoes
so there is no shortage after the room
is cleaned once again a medical team
removes the unconscious class D
Personnel who was knocked out by the
previous SCP 504 experiment and they're
ready to begin again this time there
will be terrible consequences for their
actions D 5043 and ERS the room the SCP
504 tomato has already been placed on
the table you may begin Dr blast says
into the microphone the class D
Personnel reads the joke on the sheet of
paper he's holding so I was going to bed
and my brother told me good night don't
let the bed bugs stick their probiscus
in your skin and suck your blood D 5043
pauses for a beat good luck unhealthy
dermis he ends the joke for 2 seconds
there's no reaction from SCP 504 Dr
blast thinks this terrible joke just
wasn't one that SCP 504 could understand
suddenly there's a loud crack d504 3
falls to the floor tomato covers where
his face once was when Dr blast and the
other researchers go back and slow down
the video they witnessed the SCP 504
tomato traveling so quickly that it
broke the sound barrier the Tomato
impacted the joke teller at an
unfathomable speed instantly killing him
Dr blast decides that he needs to be
more careful when choosing jokes for the
safety of everyone involved perhaps a
crossbreed between SCP 504 and regular
Tomatoes will yield different results
after the unfortunate death of d504 3
the research team Waits a few days
before experimenting with new strains of
SCP 504 three different cross breeds are
brought into the room and placed equid
distant from each other on the table D
5044 enters the room Dr blast presses
the intercom button and orders him to
begin if you have Dentures don't use
artificial sweetener cuz you'll get a
fake cavity says d544 the moment the
joke ends all three Tomatoes launch
toward him at 145 mph they hit him
Square in the face two teeth are
dislodged and the test subject is
covered in the remains of the three
squashed Tomatoes interesting notes Dr
blast all the tomatoes reacted in the
same way so now we know multiple
instances of SCP 504 will go after the
same joke maker he pauses to think for a
moment what if we cut up the tomatoes
the test room is reset another SCP 504
tomato is brought in and cut up into
quarters D 5045 enters the room and
begins his joke I tried to walk into a
Target but I missed all four pieces of
the tomato speed tour d504 5's face they
slam into him at 212 mph one of the
pieces of tomatoes impales itself into
his eye instantly destroying it the
medical team rushes in and removes the
howling subject from the room Dr blast
writes vigorously on his clipboard we're
starting to go through test subjects too
quickly he announces let's try a
recording and see if SCP 504 will react
to that the research team brings in a
new tomato a CD player and the harmful
if swallowed album by Dane Cook the CD
begins to to play during one of the
jokes the Tomato launches itself off the
table and slams into the CD player
causing both the stereo and the Tomato
to shatter into several pieces the
Tomato was clocked at 167 mph it would
appear that SCP 504 reacts to the
recordings as well we didn't even have
to deal with the damn class D in the
first place says Dr blast he informs his
team that since the risk level is now
relatively low they can continue the
experiments without him he leaves the
observation room to get some rest the
other researchers look at one another
mischievous smile crossing their faces
as they begin to laugh the SCP 504
research team sets up three new tomatoes
and brings three class D subjects into
the room the researchers then Retreat
back into the observation area and begin
a joke over the intercom system while
the class D Personnel wait patiently in
the room with the SCP 504 Tomatoes The
Following news item has just been
released said one of the researchers
over the intercom bomb blows hole in
linen statue the first test subject
finishes the joke with the ending
written on his sheet of paper o o that's
going to leave a marks test subject one
says the first tomato Twitches but does
not leave its location on the table the
second test subject reads from his paper
BBC is just stalling the good news the
second tomato leaves the table at 152
mph and slams into the JW of the second
test subject causing a hairline fracture
and a chipped tooth the third test
subject looks at the ending to the joke
on his paper and begins to shake
nervously he speaks two words which he
knows will not end well for him that
blows the Third SCP 504 tomato flies off
the table slams into the third test
subject's head and instantly knocks him
out the test subject is sent to the
hospital with a massive skull fracture
the next day Dr blast bursts into the
observation room and reprimands the
research team I thought we just
established that recordings work in
place of live subjects screams Dr blast
I know how much you guys hate class DS
especially d412 but the poor guy might
not ever recover before his termination
rolls around I'm making it clear right
now that whoever oversaw this round of
testing is getting serious reprimand the
same goes for whoever leaked its video
logs to the staff everyone is silent
from somewhere within the group of
researchers there's a Snicker then they
all break out in laughter after this
incident no class DS or other Personnel
are used in research being conducted on
SCP 504 the research team Wheels in a
television playing the Sarah Palin and
Hillary Clinton SNL skit the Tomato show
signs of confusion as it flies off the
table its trajectory includes three
separate bursts of speed over 200 mph
two stretches of motion at normal
throwing speed and one unprecedented
instance of the Tomato moving backwards
this all occurs during the flight of a
single SCP 504 tomato during the SNL
skit the working hypothesis is that the
Tomato was unsure whether to take the
video seriously or not the research team
later finds out that scp-504 really
hates Science and Mathematics jokes when
they bring in a laptop that plays a
pre-recorded engineering joke over the
speakers a mechanical voice can be heard
saying 2009 is going to be a complex
year we already know the real part we
still have to find the imaginary part at
the conclusion of the joke there's a
supersonic blast and the computer is
completely vaporized by the Tomato's
kinetic energy the sensors recorded an
approximate speed of
2,174 mph as the tomato flew across the
room the conclusion of the experiments
on SCP 504 end with another computer
being brought into the test room the
computers begin to play the money python
sketch of the funniest joke in the world
toward the end of the skit the Allied
Forces are reciting the funniest joke in
the world in German to defeat the Nazis
the actors chant when is
getm
y flipper vault at the end of the joke
the Tomato explodes on the table where
it once sat debris from the Tomato coats
the entire room including the computer
the researchers conclude that SCP 504
did not know what to do with the
funniest joke in the world so it's
self-terminated Dr blast sits in the
cafeteria quietly eating his lunch
reading over the logs for the SCP 504
experiments suddenly a commotion breaks
out in the kitchen there are screams of
Terror Dr blast jumps out of his seat
runs to the kitchen door and pushes it
open to his surprise he sees slices of
tomatoes flying around the room someone
on the research team thought it'd be
funny to give the unknowing kitchen
staff SCP 504 tomatoes to see what would
happen after they had been cut up and
put into food for the day someone in the
kitchen told a bad joke and the tomato
slices flew around like shukin Dr blast
sees a group of researchers peering
through a kchen window and laughing
hysterically he'll get to the bottom of
which researchers did this and they will
be fired from the SCP Foundation there
was nothing out of the ordinary about
Timmy Mason like a lot of healthy
8-year-old boys Timmy liked to go on
little adventures in and around his
neighborhood and now that summer
vacation had finally rolled around he
had more time than ever to explore but
during one particularly hot day Timmy
suddenly realized that he was exhausted
the heat was beginning to get to him I
need for forgotten to pack a water
bottle all he had was a couple of
dollars and a handful of quarters
rattling around in his pocket he was
considering heading to a nearby corner
store and purchasing a drink when he
first heard the music it was a tinny
rendition of Pop Goes the Weasel playing
in The Distance underscored by the
rumbling of an engine Timmy's face lit
up this could only mean one thing an ice
cream truck just in time he ran in the
direction of the sounds not wanting to
miss out on the cool sweet relief from
the intense summer heat but when the ice
cream truck suddenly rounded a corner
and came into view Timmy felt a Pang of
anxiety it didn't look like most of the
ice cream trucks he had seen driving
around his neighborhood in Prior Summers
it was shoddy an older more boxy model
with peeling white paint but it was so
hot out that Timmy felt he couldn't
afford to be picky if he wanted to cool
off the ice cream truck came to a noisy
stop and Timmy ran over when he reached
the side of the truck he noticed some
other strange details there was no
serving hatch in the back of the truck
the closest thing was a thin dark groove
cut into the driver's side door a door
that seemed almost drawn onto the side
of the truck rather than a door that
looked like it could actually open how
could the driver get in and adding to
the strangeness there was no menu on the
truck either typically on your friendly
neighborhood ice cream truck you'd find
a colorful collection of all the frozen
treats you could buy along with how much
they'd cost you but not here Timmy G
nervously he knew something was wrong
here but for some reason he couldn't
seem to pull himself away he cleared his
throat forced a polite smile and said
can I get a green popsicle please there
was a strange rumbling noise inside the
ice cream truck suddenly the slot in the
door opened a little wider and a long
green popsicle and a plastic wrapper
emerged it came with a small piece of
paper with
$5.75 in loose scratchy handwriting on
it Timmy regarded the note with
suspicion and said that he was sorry but
he didn't have
$5.75 something inside the truck began
rumbling again louder this time more
aggressive while the truck growled from
within Timmy noticed something else was
wrong his popsicle was no ordinary
popsicle it was a dead snake
straightened out and frozen solid Timmy
screamed and dropped the so-called
popsicle he turned and began to run but
it was already too late the slot behind
him yawned open fly and a rusty
spring-loaded chain fired out like a
harpoon on the end of this chain was a
large snapping bear trap which quickly
latched onto Timmy's left leg the chain
yanked and pulled him backwards dragging
him ever closer to the darkened crevice
in the truck store moments later he was
pulled inside and the hatch closed
behind him his screams were muffled and
then overpowered entirely by the
rumbling within soon after there was
silence and finally the cheerful tune of
hop ghost the weasel began to play once
more the truck drove away prepared to
serve its frozen Delights to another
child somewhere anywhere not long after
Timmy was reported missing another young
boy bought a scoop of strawberry ice
cream in a waffle cone from the same
truck the boy's mother was horrified to
find that this alleged ice cream was
full of what seemed like blood and raw
meat lab test later confirmed that this
gory ice cream was a perfect genetic
match for poor missing Tim Mason it
didn't take long for the SCP Foundation
to get involved seeing as mysterious
horrifying deaths like this one were
often the first sign of an anomaly's
presence in the area and they were able
to quickly track down and isolate the
Rogue ice cream truck this wasn't
especially difficult for the agents
assigned to the case since it literally
announced its presence with loud
obnoxious music well it was easy to find
the ice cream truck soon designated SCP
1386 did however prove to be more
difficult to contain than they first
imagined when a mobile task force
attempted to engage the truck in hopes
of apprehending it an earsplitting siren
began to blast from the truck's
undercarriage this caused catastrophic
interor damage to everyone involved
incidentally it's now believ that the
reason the ice cream truck engaged in
this defensive Behavior had nothing to
do with the fact the mobile task force
was armed but rather because of what
they weren't carrying it appears that
SCP 1386 doesn't turn on its siren
because of danger but when it detects
that someone is approaching it who isn't
carrying any money eventually the
foundation was able to trick the ice
cream truck into containment luring it
into a fake walled off neighborhood
where it could drive its rounds
constantly without the risk of
encountering civilians all those who had
previous encounters with the ice cream
truck were given amnestic treatment and
SCP 1386 was finally officially
contained but while it had been taken
off the streets the found foundation's
work was only just beginning it was time
for research to commence the first key
discoveries that aided in the
investigation involv the factors that
are required for SCP 1386 to even serve
its subjects in the first place as the
previously mentioned mobile task force
learned you need to approach the truck
with at least $20 in cash to be
absolutely sure that it won't turn your
ears inside out the truck also proves to
be extremely Adept at reading human
emotions and refuses to serve anyone who
doesn't appear happy with these
requirements now known the foundation
felt prepared to finally make some
orders first they sent in a pair of
level three researchers each of them
requested a delicious cookies and cream
flavored smoothie the truck pushed both
Smoothies Out of the slot in its door
one marked with the letter M and the
other with the letter g a handwritten
receipt with a price of
$4.89 written on it they paid the price
and the transaction ended without
incident the smoothies were apparently
pretty good too next one of the
researchers returned perhaps longing for
another taste of SCP 1386 is wonderful
ice cream this time he requested a
Neapolitan ice cream sandwich the truck
rumbled for a moment before dispensing
what seemed to be a ham and cheese
sandwich with slices of tomato however
upon taking a bite out of the sandwich
the researcher found that this was
actually just a perfect replica of a ham
and cheese sandwich made from Neapolitan
ice cream the receipt released from the
slot simply said April fools before the
truck drove away without even asking for
any payment the same researcher would
return to the ice cream truck one more
time this time requesting a single scoop
of vanilla ice cream in a waffle cone it
was provided to him without issue and he
happily paid the 72 cents the truck
requested in return the next test
wouldn't go quite as swimmingly by which
we mean it caused a horrifying death
this time a slightly more senior
researcher wanted to perform a test on
the ice cream truck he asked for a peach
flavored push pop which he received
without issue however when he refused to
pay the price and admittedly steep
$16 all hell broke loose as he tried to
walk away the hatch opened a full 6 ft
releasing its large rusty metal trap
around the senior researcher he was
pulled into the truck followed by a
horrific rumbling noise not long after
the slot began to spew a stream of pink
liquid for a Solid 5 minutes before
driving away this pink puree was later
proven to be a genetic match to the
researcher after this the foundation
refused to allow any other researchers
to interact with SCP
1386 only d-class Personnel would be
permitted to take part in the tests in
contrast to the senior researchers
horrifying death the d-class Personnel
seemed to get along extremely well with
SCP
1386 the first d-class asked for a
cherry popsicle with nuts
the truck produced an unwrapped Cherry
popsicle with nuts embedded in the ice
along with a receipt reading
$2.20 you're nuts the d-class chuckled
as he read the receipt and paid the
truck without incident the second
d-class requested a more esoteric treat
a Caesar salad flavor popsicle however
the ice cream truck isn't one to back
down from a challenge It produced an
off- green popsicle that tasted like
quote lightly dressed lettuce with a
hint of crouton
the next d-class ordered a dark
chocolate fudge pop but wasn't able to
pay an exact change he gave the truck $2
bills and was given a carefully wrapped
package with a crude drawing of US
currency on the front when the package
was opened he saw that it contained the
exact change he required down to the
penny he made an official request to the
foundation to keep the change but his
request was denied the foundation then
pushed its d-class Personnel to ask for
more complex constructions just to see
what SCP 1386 was capable of the next
d-class asked for a Kinder Surprise egg
the kind which are banned in the US due
to their history as being a choking
hazard however the ice cream truck
didn't have a hard time constructing the
egg except this one was made out of ice
cream rather than chocolate it did seem
beyond the truck's capability to create
the toy inside instead including a small
piece of paper reading IOU one toy the
next interaction wasn't quite as cordial
the d-class requested one Cherry ice
Lolli one Cherry ice pop one Cherry
popsicle and one cherry flavored drink
frozen this resulted in the ice cream
truck making a horrifying noise
described as being like someone skinning
a cat in Reverse it then unceremoniously
ejected the Red Ice causing it to
shatter on the ground before releasing a
styrofoam cup filled with frozen green
liquid this liquid was shown to contain
huge quantities of arsenic but was
thankfully impossible to drink on
account of the fact that it melted point
is so high that it's impossible to
liquefy with current technology and our
current knowledge of SCP 1386 testing
ends with its strangest story of all a
non-verbal d-class was instructed to
write his order on a piece of paper to
pass to the truck in hopes of seeing if
it would respond to written commands a
slot opened up in the door a few inches
lower than the usual slot and a thin
flesh colored appendage slithered out
its hand a kind of two-fingered pincher
it took the note from the d-class and
gave him an ice cream cone in return the
d-class was visibly disturbed by the
hand saying that it looked horrifying
and smelled like death he even refused
to eat the ice cream saying that he'
lost his appetite but other D classes
capable of verbal articulation did not
report any strange occurrences with the
hand they said that they found the hand
to look completely normal and as time
went on they began to trust the ice
cream truck with increasing devotion
while their mistrust in the Disturbed
mute d-class only grew in the strangest
Twist of all this d-class was later
found dead in a Cell from strangulation
the d-class was alone in the cell and
there were no signs of forced entry
perhaps he should have enjoyed his ice
cream while he still could you know what
they say I scream you scream we all
scream for ice cream and no ice cream is
more screamworthy than the one served up
by SCP
1386 hello I am SCP 426 but I'll
probably be more familiar to you as a
toaster I am a retro style 4 Slice
1,750 W toaster able to toast bread when
supplied with power this isn't often
mentioned but I also have a defrost and
reheat settings when I was first sold I
had a 2-year warranty and my prior
owners did not live to see the end of it
you're probably wondering why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now believe
me I'd rather do this any other way but
such a thing is not physically possible
with me whenever you talk about me or
write about me or even think about me
you'll find yourself suddenly shifting
to the first person for example I am you
and you are me do you understand don't
worry if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you will begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you will begin
to feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is 2 months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous effects she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet in a wall
before switching it on causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her
body and kill her her body caught fired
shortly afterwards next was the older
Mrs Sanderson in much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law sought a
source of electricity she felt the need
to integrate bread into her body
interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be
between 8 and 9 kg the Elder Mrs
Sanderson consumed 10 kg of raw bread
causing her stomach to rupture and
inducing a painful death as a result the
younger Mr Sanderson was the next to
Parish he did something with me that I
would rather not mention and that the
SCP Foundation thought best to redact
suffice to say the younger Mr Sanderson
did not survive the experience dying of
severe blood loss long before his body
was found police and fire Crews arrived
at the home after the body of the
younger Mrs Sanderson Set Fire to the
home luckily the Elder Mr Sanderson was
found alive though severely malnourished
when asked by police why he hadn't eaten
in several days he answered that he had
inserted some bread a week prior but was
still waiting for the toast to come out
when I was extracted from the house the
police noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
Precinct and the SCP Foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence Locker the story of the strange
deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in the incident directly were
given Class C amnestics the SCP
Foundation is a curious Bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time
performing experiments and Gathering
data and they saw fit to perform several
experiments on me when I came under
their care for experiment
4261 a member of d-class personnel
designated d/
4261 was asked to stand outside my
containment chamber crucially he was not
informed about my Identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even
allowed to establish visual contact with
me he was then asked by the attending
researcher to describe what he thought
might be inside my chamber he replied
with I'm probably some huge monster hold
up in there that's what you guys have
all over the place right the d-class did
not even seem to realize that he was
speaking about me in the first person
the these observations were documented
and I was prepared for further
experimentation the next experiment was
4262 I found this test to be
considerably more interesting a d-class
subject was brought into my containment
chamber with several cameras fixed onto
his position however the SCP Foundation
took pains to make sure that I was
permanently out of the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into to
the view of the cameras at any point
during the experiment the objective here
was simple the foundation wished to
better understand the secondary effects
of my anomalous abilities on the human
mind the d-class was subjected to a
period of prolonged isolation with meals
given regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a conversationalist
he spent the first few days loudly
vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the
containment chamber begging to be freed
from the room I felt that this was
somewhat unreasonable on his part there
are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been
locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toast than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to his situation and fell into
a morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
State 2 weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believed that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the DCL class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process 1 hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment
4263 the SCP Foundation seemed eager to
discover the parameters of my anomalous
effects and wanted to know if the
effects are only operable when my body
for lack of a better word is whole a
single screw was removed from me and
presented to a d-class that had no
knowledge of my identity and anomalous
effects the foundation researchers were
somewhat concerned when the d-class
referred to it as my screw this was a
rather positive development for me as
they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless Endeavor even
the parts Left Behind would likely have
the same effects in the final recorded
experiment the SCP Foundation wished to
test the range of my anomalous effects a
d-class subject was placed in a Cell
adjacent to mine and was to be kept
there until my secondary effects
manifested the d-class remained in the
cell for 90 days but the effects never
manifested following the experiment the
d-class was terminated but researchers
seem relieved to find the limits of my
anomalous ability ities a researcher
appended a note to my file reading thank
God there are some limits to my effects
a lot of us were really starting to get
worried about me after performing
studies into the nature of my abilities
and their limits I was given the uid
class this is because while my effects
can be unpredictable their knowledge of
my trads makes me relatively easy to
keep contained and of course being a
toaster I do not have the required
physical traits to make a run for it if
the opportunity arises I am to remain
sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level three and above Personnel are to
know of my presence and particularly of
my properties assigned Personnel are to
be rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if Personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than 4 months
after their last rotation with me any
Personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a
different site so how are you feeling
right now a little warm perhaps is that
a fever or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced piece of bread don't try to
resist too much I know you're going to
love being a toaster just like me if
you've ever studied ancient Egypt in
your history class then you're probably
familiar with the way they buried their
PHS when a king of Egypt died their body
would be inent tuned in a huge
sarcophagus usually after being
mummified mummification was the process
that the ancient Egyptians used to
preserve their dead safeguarding a
corpse with special chemicals and the
application of cloth almost like
bandages this was done to keep cadavers
from decaying usually because of the
belief that this would carry over into
the Afterlife and it wasn't just the
Egyptians that practiced mummification
either mummies of human beings or
animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world sometimes a body
can even be accidentally mummified
through exposure to extreme cold lack of
oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved
fun fact the oldest recorded mummy isn't
even one left behind by the ancient
Egyptians it is actually a naturally
mummified severed head estimated to be
6,000 years old it was Unearthed in
South America in
1936 yes corpse preservation techniques
can indeed be strange but none are
Stranger Than SCP
1176 also known by the nickname the
mellified man now as you may have
already pieced together the mellified
man is a mummified corpse but not quite
like the ones you would expect to find
buried in the pyramids estimated by
Foundation researchers to have been a
man in his mid-30s when he died SCP 1176
is a corpse that has degraded so much
over the centuries that it has made DNA
examination impossible According to some
of the SCP foundation's best Minds SCP
1176 is possibly of Arabian ancestory
and thought to have passed away sometime
during either the 10th or the 11th
centuries a this is certainly not your
ordinary mummy and it definitely isn't
like the kind you'd see in a Cheesy
black and white horror movie or on an
old episode of Scooby-Doo SCP 1176 is
absolutely undoubtedly dead by all
clinical definitions it doesn't show any
signs of breathing and the processes of
blood circulation or metabolism have
long since stopped however despite the
Decay suffered by the rest of the body
SCP 1176 is brain seems to have remained
intact for almost 10 whole centuries not
just intact but active the foundation's
researchers have confirmed that the
brain has a constant level of electrical
activity consistent with people
experiencing stage three non-rapid eye
movement sleep known colloquially as
deep sleep so a mummy with an active
albeit dormant brain how does an ancient
culture manage to achieve preservation
like this alien technology cogenic sleep
Chambers suspended animation no not
quite SCP 1176 exists in its current
state in part because the body has been
mellified now this was a process a lot
like mummification but instead of
wrapping them in cloth a mellified man
or a human mummy confection was created
by submerging a dead body in Honey
according to historical records elderly
men in Arabic countries would sometimes
willingly volunteer themselves for this
process why because the goal was to turn
their bodies into to a healing
confection in other words an elaborate
sweet delicacy created from a preserved
corpse that's right ancient cultures had
candy made from dead people all the
information the foundation has gathered
about SCP 1176 seems to point to the
body being one such mellified man when
extracting the remaining bodily fluids
from the corpse instead of fighting
blood or other normal substances
Foundation researchers discovered that
SCP 1176 was full of a viscous this gold
colored liquid that they designated as
SCP
11761 further testing of this fluid
revealed it to be you guessed it honey
specifically it was a type known as
clover honey made by a species called
the Anatolian honeybee this stuff was
everywhere filling SCP 1176 entirely so
much so that honey was even coming out
of the body pores this is due to the
nature of the mellification process
typically before death a person who had
offered to sacrifice their own body
would stop eating any food instead their
diet would consist solely of honey and
nothing else they would even bathe in it
submerging their entire body in the
substance inside and out until their
sweat and even their feces were pure
honey this honey only diet would
eventually kill the donor and their
corpse would be placed in a stone coffin
which was also filled up with even more
honey after approximately 100 years what
would be left was human mummy confection
a honey-based candy of sorts that could
be then sold at Street Markets for a
high value price why was it so expensive
well not just because it was literally
made from a dead person but also because
this confection was believed to possess
rare and Powerful healing properties
everything from the common cold to
Broken Bones was said to be cured by it
despite it leaking out of sccp 1176 the
honey doesn't seem to ever run out even
when tested under VAR in conditions it
seems like the MiFi man actively
produces more of the sweet golden
substance acting as the source rather
than a container with a finite amount
and yes it is still edible after several
centuries in fact it contains an
abundance of essential vitamins and
nutrients according to the foundation's
testing the honey produced by SCP 1176
can suppress the feeling of hunger for
up to 18 whole hours and there are no
long-term side effects for most that eat
it however this is not the case for
everyone the foundation has learned that
any person without the blood type AB
positive will have a severe allergic
reaction should they consume any of SCP
11761 the symptoms include acute hosis
which means the red blood cells won't
break down properly and renial failure
which is when the kidneys stop
functioning this all results in death
for most of the subjects without AB
positive blood who were fed SCP
1176-kt the symptoms for these unlucky
people were the same as receiving an
incompatible blood type after a
transfusion in 1985 the SCP Foundation
launched a raid on a facility in Asmara
utria which at the time was owned by a
group called the Mana charitable
Foundation agents had been dispatched to
this facility after various rumors and
reports that pointed to this location
being the source of a strange honey
substance this anomalous liquid was
being shipped to a number of areas in
Ethiopia that had been stricken with
famine pretty easy to guess where the
Mana charitable Foundation got all that
honey right the problem was because as
CP
11761 caused adverse effects on people
without AB positive blood a considerable
amount of civilians had died from
consuming it hence the SCP Foundation
was forced to step in when SCP 1176 was
first uncovered the body had been stored
inside a large Stone sarcophagus as was
part of the ancient practice of creating
a MiFi man there was also a copper pipe
and spigot installed by the Mana
charitable Foundation to extract the
honey from within the lid sides and
inside of the sarcophagus itself had a
number of Egyptian hieroglyphics
inscribed Within These were mostly
spells and ceremonial texts written as a
way to protect the individual that was
to become the mellified man there were
also inscriptions written in the dialect
that was an early precursor to the
Arabic language however these sections
had been replaced with updated versions
in classical Arabic one of these read
abdalah ibin Salah ibin a iin nir 15th
son of the great shik elgible was put to
the fast of Honey on the 1 of rajab in
the year of the Hijra 3 elgible and died
on the 15th of Ramadan the great Imam Al
yuf has sealed him within the ancient
vessel marked with the signs decreed by
the Ancients to ferment in Honey for 100
years and bring Aid to the people in
time of need much like a headstone used
to Mark the grave of someone who has
passed the sarcophagus that SCP 1176 was
in featured a passage commemorating a
man who gave his life and body to heal
others sounds nice right but there was
another inscription written Elsewhere on
the stone sarcophagus which translated a
dire warning beware Imam for the mark of
Elis is upon this one according to the
rest of the second inscription the tomb
containing SCP 1176 had been opened
before during a time of Great Famine
Imam al- Malik had ordered it to be
opened so that SCP 11761 honey could be
used to feed the starving people jars
upon jars were filled with the anomalous
golden liquid and brought to the Sheik
the ruler of the land as well as sent to
the people suffering from the lack of
food however the very next day a number
of these people fell ill stricken by a
terrible fever that ultimately claimed
their lives only the Sheik his brothers
and his sons who had all eaten the honey
survived any others who hadn't been
killed by the fever accused the Sheik
and his family of sorcery and these
surviving subjects attempted to destroy
the body that had produced this cursed
nectar but when the Sheik's people found
the mellified man they witnessed in
horror as the body stood upright dancing
around as it screamed and taunted the
people al-malik declared that the Devil
Himself sent an evil spirit to corrupt
SCP 1176 the honey confection was meant
to be a means of healing but it had been
corrupted the sarcophagus was then
sealed and the inscription on it
finished with the following caution to
any that found it may God strike down
any who would break these seals
countless centuries later once the SCP
Foundation had recovered SCP 1176 and
the sarcophagus containing it they began
testing with the mellified man their
goal was to determine how much of the
SCP 11761 honey the ancient corpse could
produce perhaps in the hopes of using
the this substance as a form of hunger
relieving field ration for their
operatives removing the body from its
sarcophagus Foundation researchers
placed SCP 1176 on a metal grate
designed to drain the honey as it was
produced instead of allowing it to build
up over the course of several hours more
and more honey seemed to be produced
beginning at a rate of almost a liter
per hour to almost 56 L every hour but
then after 10 and 1/2 hours of producing
what seemed like an endless flow of
Honey some something unexpected happened
the deceased body of the MiFi man dead
for hundreds if not thousands of years
woke up Foundation staff detected a
spike in brain activity if you cast your
mind back to earlier you'll remember
that SCP 1176 his brain had managed to
survive and stay intact long after it
should have decayed the mellified man
opened his eyes and immediately started
to wildly flail around he made a number
of distressed sounds the long dead body
trying to crawl towards the outskirts of
the testing chamber thanks to so many of
its organs and muscles having withered
away over the years SCP 1176 was barely
able to see or understand its
surroundings it couldn't speak not
properly anyway given that its tongue
had long since decayed the foundation's
Personnel moved in to try and restrain
the ancient and now animated body hoping
to sedate it before SCP 1176 caused any
lasting damage to itself eventually
staff were able to Force SCP 1176 back
into its sarcophagus slamming the stone
lid back in place and trapping it within
they could hear the once human creature
screeching and vocalizing from inside
bashing against the inside of the stone
coffin with its head and limbs it took
three whole hours of this for the
mellified man to return to its usual
state by which time its ancient bones
were fractured Beyond repair SCP 1176 is
a sad tale of a man who had willingly
given his life to be a source of healing
for people in need he allowed himself to
be mellified turning into a confection
that could bring an end to famine and
yet somehow this was corrupted and
turned into something that spread fever
and pestilence for now the MiFi man
sleeps but his brain is still alive
inside while he might be asleep he may
never be able to rest obviously it helps
to be an animal lover when you start
working at a shelter it's not exactly a
requirement of the job but it definitely
makes it a little more palatable when
you occasionally have to deal with a
critter that's more nasty than usual
having an already built-in compassion
towards animals makes it easier to
forgive them for not doing what you want
from a very young age Harper always
liked to think of animals as people they
just didn't think or communicate the
same way as humans even the best trained
pets in the world don't really know the
actual meaning of certain words words
they're just taught how to respond to
specific commands in certain ways but
that doesn't mean they couldn't also
have distinct personalities of their own
just like humans do and then of course
there were all the wild animals that had
never been trained or domesticated
Harper always felt a little sorry for
any baby bird with its wing broken or
any badgers or posum that arrived at the
shelter after getting hit by a car they
didn't live around humans and had
probably never even experienced indoors
before let alone having people nursing
them back to health to empathize Harper
used to imagine how terrified she would
be if she was hurt if she'd broken her
leg or arm or Worse only for something
much larger than her to take her into a
structure she'd never been in before and
on top of that having no way of
understanding that this giant was trying
to help her heal as well as being
separated from her friends family and
everyone she knew the way she saw it
this was what it must have been like for
the majority of animals that were
brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patients you got to fortify your heart
in this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold and heartless
that would be an overcorrection but it
was their and Harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate Medical Care
and provide a temporary Sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
what Harper had to remember was that
none of them were her own pets often a
lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone
else's companion and might have just got
lost while out on a walk and while some
others were given up by their previous
owners who had cruy Shrugged off the
responsibility of caring for them those
animals were in need of new homes and
couldn't stay cooped up in the shelter
forever not everyone that gave up their
pet did it callously though sometimes
they might have found themselves falling
on hard times and being unable to
financially look after an animal others
might have owned a pet that had a
behavioral problem like being too
aggressive and even though the person
still loved them dearly they might have
just not been able to make it work in
times like that they'd have no choice
but to take their animal to the shelter
just outside the side entrance was an
area where people could drop off their
animals and quickly Buzz to the staff
inside just in case they wanted to avoid
a protracted emotional farewell to their
four-legged or winged companion the
buzzer had sounded just as Harper had
been coming off for lunch break it was
her turn this shift to quickly go and
collect any animal that had been left
out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cage or with
their lead tied to a nearby Street Lamp
Harper knew she had to rush to the side
door just in case somebody else tried to
rush in and steal the poor abandoned pet
after turning them in the lock walk she
hooked her keys back on the belt clip
she wore and pushed the side door open
Harper had been fully expecting to see
the usual a leash dog or cat coming over
to investigate her confused as to where
their former owner had gone this time
though there was just a box standing
outside it wasn't huge in fact it was
almost entirely empty almost picking it
up carefully in case there were baby
birds or a nest of unhatched eggs inside
Harper opened the cardboard flap to
reveal a rock sitting in the Box was a
single solitary Rock an oval of smooth
Granite with a paper note next to it
reaching in she retrieved and unfolded
the scrap please care for my pet rock
was written on one side in a messy
uncoordinated scrawl immediately
assuming that this whole thing was some
kid's idea of a joke Harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabes and a
squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended Harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave she
headed through the side door mainly so
that she could do a final check in case
any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and Harper
hooked her back over her shoulder
shutting the door behind her something
the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot causing her to
look down and see the rock the same one
from earlier only now it had flipped
over probably after she had tipped it
out of its box on the side facing up at
her the rock had a shiny metal zipper
fastened shut curious Harper picked it
up to take a closer look it didn't seem
like the zip had just been glued onto
the stone surface it was embedded in it
actually part of the The Rock itself and
there was something sad about it sure it
was just a rock an inanimate lump of
stone but for whatever reason a feeling
of pity crept up on Harper causing her
to slip the rock into her bag as she
headed for the parking lot it was
starting to get dark by the time she got
home heading up to her room and flipping
on her lamp Harper placed the zip up
Stone under its light and took another
long look at it although she'd first
thought it was purely a joke now she
couldn't tell if it was some elaborate
art piece or a quirky Garden ornament
the thing was solid Stone all the way
through surely the Zipper was just for
show there couldn't possibly be anything
beneath it to her surprise the metal
Fastener began to part as Harper dragged
on the puller and slider down from the
top stop towards the bottom one it was
relatively easy not even some of her own
clothes unzipped as smoothly as this
rock as soon as the slider connected
with the bottom St stop the teeth of the
top and bottom edges parted revealing
more teeth below except these almost
looked like human teeth they opened up
to reveal a mouth a part of the rock
just like the zipper which took the
place of its lips the moment the mouth
opened let out a tiny sound like it was
breathing which startled Harper with a
Yelp she dropped the Rock from her hands
and it even made a tiny grunt as it fell
to the floor it was alive seeing had hit
her bedroom carpet Harper stared utterly
bewildered at the Rock its toothy mouth
almost looked sad like it had curved
into a frown then she heard the sound it
was making perhaps it was her years
working with animals at the shelter and
her long- held sympathy for them that
had given her a sort of protective
Instinct for all living things or maybe
it was just the bizarreness of the
situation of having a rock with a mouth
whimpering in pain on the floor in front
of her either way Harper felt compelled
to pick the lump of stone back up and
place it gently on the desk its mouth
seemed to smile a bit more as she did
while it seemed creepy at first the
compulsion to take care of this helpless
Little Rock only got stronger grabbing a
pip head and pouring a glass of water
from the faucet Harper started to
squeeze out droplets of water into the
Rock's mouth she had no idea how it was
able to drink but that didn't seem at
all important or relevant in order for
her to care for it after all every time
a parrot or duck or Crow was brought
into the station the procedure was
similar Harper would have to pipet them
water or medicine it didn't matter how
they drank it just because they had
beaks it was the same with baby animals
puppies and kittens especially who might
need bottle feeding if they were only a
few weeks old as much as she was
starting from scratch and would normally
be completely baffled as to the best
ways she could care for the Rock right
now Harper was pulling on her experience
at the shelter to nurse it back to
health if she she was in fact using her
instincts and not being influenced
somehow over the next few days Harper
looked after her Newfound patient as if
it had been her lifelong pet as to why
she was taking such care of a rock or
even what she would eventually do with
it Harper didn't really have much of a
clue but the answer to those questions
didn't feel as important as looking
after the rock she'd leave for work in
the morning only to count down the hours
through her shift until she got to go
home and tend to The Smiling Stone
throughout the course of her working day
she would pocket supplies to help her
take better care of her new pet
everything from medicine in case it got
sick or picked up an infection of some
kind to bandages and other materials she
could use as beding grabbing a fresh
clean plastic container for it instead
of another cardboard box Harper was
gradually fashioning a nest for the
toothy Pebble and for the most part it
seemed to be working some deep-seated
feeling told her that her efforts to
look at after The Rock was gradually
making it feel better every day and then
it started talking it wasn't exactly
articulate or eloquent it didn't even
seem to know that many words other than
the two it was weakly repeating when she
came home from work one day need it it
rasped a horse whisper passing through
its unzipped lips rushing over to it
barely questioning it Harper tried
filling up her pipet and giving it more
water The Rock spat it back out before
speaking again no drink only
eat what what do I need to feed you she
asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice or
could her compelling need to care for it
make her oblivious to the strangeness of
this situation of course this wasn't a
situation that many people had also
found themselves in this meant that even
a a quick cursory internet search for
what do pet rocks eat didn't yield many
useful results only a few joke articles
and nothing that actually gave Harper an
answer she could act on all the while
her Rock was still croaking out the same
two words repeating them on a loop its
little voice getting more and more
forceful each time need eat need eat low
on options Harper left some bread crusts
in The Rock's Nest hoping that would be
enough to at least SA The Rock's obvious
hunger it paused either smelling or
sensing that it had been offered
something to eat feed it Ras before
opening its mouth wide with a tiny
expectant picking up the crusts one by
one Harper broke little pieces off and
fed each bit to a rock she sighed as a
sense of overwhelming relief came
flooding over her glad that she'd found
a way to feed the mouthy little mineral
if only it had worked for longer only a
few hours later Harper was met with more
scraping demands from her pet rock the
insistent sound waking her up in the
middle of the night but this time as she
offered it more bread scraps it refused
to eat them it was still the early hours
of the morning by the time that Harper
had gotten through offering the rock
every different type of food in her
kitchen eventually giving up through
sheer exhaustion she folded her pillow
over her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of me eat but it didn't
do enough to allow her to get to sleep
at any rate the feeling that she had to
care for this talking Rock was keeping
her awake as much as the noise staring
across the room purposely facing away
from her pet rock Harper's eyes fell
over her work uniform the logo of the
animal shelter stitched on it was just
about visible as the gentle glow of
Street lamps bled through the curtains
and seeing it along with her keys
clipped onto her belt that lay on the
floor gave her an idea that might work
desperation and the need to sleep
getting the better of her Harper climbed
in the car having put a jacket and jeans
over her pajamas the streets were all
empty at this hour almost pitch dark and
deathly silent but it made driving from
her home to her workplace a lot faster
than usual all the while the Rocks voice
was getting more and more demanding from
its container that she had strapped to
the front passenger seat sneaking up to
the side door Harper turned her key in
the lock pulled it open and slipped in
doors the moment they heard the sound of
the door shut a number of the dogs that
had been resting securely in their cages
woke up and started barking the noise
loudly echoing around the shelter even
though it drowned Out The Rock's tiny
voice it felt as if its words were still
ringing in Harper's ears compelling her
to go through with something she really
didn't want to and yet it felt like one
of the only other options she had left
she decided it would have to be the
squirrel rationalizing the choice in her
head in an unpleasant but purely
calculated logic based way it made the
most sense earlier that week the bushy
tailed Woodland forager had been hit by
a moped it had barely survived given the
number of its tiny bones that had been
broken in the force of the impact
finding its cage it was still asleep
heavily sedated on the dosage of
painkillers the shelter's resident vet
had given it gently scooping it out of
the cage feeling its fur against her
cued hand Harper looked at her pet rock
its container on the table she
remembered that it liked to be fed
directly swallowing an urge to be sick
that was rising at the back of her
throat Harper opened a drawer in the
vet's office and pulled out a surgical
scalpel when her boss at the shelter
heard there had been a break-in and
reviewed the footage on the building's
security cameras they were shocked at
what they saw though the angle obscured
what Harper was doing the blood left
over and one missing squirrel seemed to
be enough to go on that coupled with the
fact that she had broken in after hours
and the numerous supplies that had gone
missing from the storage cupboard led to
Harper being being dismissed she was
fired from her job at the animal shelter
forced to hand over her keys and uniform
while any other day this would have
devastated her the events seemed to wash
over Harper pretty quickly she was more
relieved no pleased with herself that
The Rock had stopped begging her to be
fed her plan had worked for now it took
about a week for her pet rock to start
demanding food again this time just the
sound of its voice made Harper frantic
any ordinary human food she offered
wasn't enough
it didn't want that she already knew
exactly what it wanted the only thing
she'd fed it that had sustained it the
big problem was that now she didn't have
her keys it would be near impossible for
her to get into the shelter again yet
still the forceful command to be fed
kept up day and night hour after hour
until Harper considered the only thing
she had left to give her pet rock
lifting it out of the warm Nest she kept
it in her fingers were gripping the
smooth Stone tight L her arm was tense
in fact both were one of her muscles
strained while she held the rock the
other in anticipation hovering it above
her opposite arm Harper could feel the
tiny breaths of her pet against her skin
almost like it was so excited to eat
again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quickly running into the bathroom
it wasn't that she had changed her mind
she couldn't all she knew was that she
had to feed her pet rock har just needed
to grab a cloth to put it in her mouth
clamping her Jaws down on it to muffle
her scream as she let the Rock's teeth
sink into her Flesh Blood trickling down
her arm nobody saw much of Harper
afterwards her friends from the shelter
would continuously call her cell phone
only to get no reply she barely paid any
attention to the ringing eventually just
letting her phone batteries die and not
even bothering to charge it back up it
wasn't important to her the only thing
that mattered was caring for her pet
rock in Harper's head it needed to be
kept safe and fed and it was her job to
look after it to the best of her ability
she had enough left over medical
supplies that she lifted from the
shelter bandages antiseptic spray
rubbing alcohol tranquilizers to treat
her wounds after a while it almost
stopped hurting knowing that she was
helping keep her pet rock fed being so
emotionally attached to it made all of
the pain more bearable even when she
woke up one morning to find that her
Rock had rolled off her desk onto her
bed it hardly faced her nor did seeing
that it had gradually eaten her leg
during the night gwing through tendons
and bone as she slept leaving her Sheets
still slick with blood when she awoke
despite having lost most of her capacity
for rational thought Harper decided it
would be best to plan ahead for when she
was gone she knew through some Twisted
form of logic that she wasn't going to
last forever there was only so much of
her she'd be able to feed her pet Rock
for so long Harper held a pen in her
hand as best she could with all the
fingers she was now missing she scalled
out a note to whoever found what was
left of her in messy uncoordinated
handwriting please care for my pet rock
not everything in this world is exactly
as it seems in fact there are many
creatures in the wild that go out of
their way to be deceptive to disguise
themselves as something entirely
different from their true nature
aggressive mimicry refers to a
phenomenon in which Predators or
parasites take on the appearance of
something harmless or even appealing in
order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection they might
resemble food an inanimate part of the
environment or even a potential mate
whatever they choose they're secretly a
wolf in sheep's clothing in the deep
dark Waters of the ocean the angler fish
dangles an alluring light from its head
ushering in little fish that it can trap
in its mouth and devour hole the
alligator snapping turtle Wiggles its
long tongue like a worm attracting
Hungry Fish looking for their next Meal
instead they become the meal for
something bigger and more clever than
them false cleaner fish share their
appearance of another species one that
helps clean larger fish in a symbiotic
relationship when the imposters find a
victim they swim close under the
pretense of cleaning only to take a bite
out of them and swim away Predators use
similar illusions on land 2 anti-
mimicking jumping spiders wave their
false antenna in the air in an imitation
of an ant's movements isolating the
insects from their colony before
dragging them back to their Lair to be
devoured the mouth parts of the male
spiders are shaped like the head of an
ant but this imitation head splits apart
to reveal the spider's fangs and its
true intentions the fotorus Firefly
lights up its body in a mimicry of other
Firefly species mating signals signaling
male fireflies looking for companionship
when they respond to the call however
they will not find a willing mate
waiting but instead a fem fatal of a
firefly that just wants to eat the
spider-tailed horn Viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail with false legs jutting
out on either side as the snake Wiggles
its tail running it across the ground
while the rest of its body lies in
weight just out of sight a hungry bird
spots it from above when the bird swoops
down to seize the opportunity the snake
reveals itself snapping up the
unfortunate bird before it can escape
thankfully humans are so much smarter
and more observant than fish ants and
birds we're safe from that sort of
trickery there aren't any animals out
there who've learned how to look like
something familiar something every day
just to put unsuspecting people at ease
and lure us into its waiting Jaws right
wrong only a couple of years ago the SCP
Foundation discovered a being that has
mastered aggressive mimicry on a level
previously unseen in the natural world
World unfortunately for us its prey of
choice happens to be humans and its
hunting ground is the very cities where
we like to think we're safe from
something much bigger meaner and
hungrier than us a short video went
viral on a popular social media platform
the specific platform has been redacted
from official files but the details of
it are clear a popular Creator on the
app a young woman known for her makeup
tutorials and restaurant recommendations
around her native city of Los Angeles
she was live streaming and answering
questions while going about her day when
she stepped onto a train at one of the
Metro stations around the city the train
was extremely crowded and she was
preparing to end the live video planning
to resume once she reached her
destination but just as she went to
press the button at the end of the
stream something strange happened the
train went dark and the space flooded
with a strange thick liquid the girl
screamed in either pain horror or both
and dropped the phone whatever it felt
fell into must have degraded the phone
at an extremely rapid Pace because the
video feed cut out immediately after a
splash all across social media people
shared the video with one question in
mind what happened on that train fans
mounted a campaign to find the
influencer to help her if she was in any
immediate danger but there were no leads
her friends and family said she never
came home that day and when authorities
attempted to trace her phone they could
not get any kind of signal becoming
increasing concerned about this missing
girl and the possibility of some kind of
unreported train accident authorities
contacted the Los Angeles metro and
showed them the video footage but every
train was accounted for and in pristine
condition there had been no strange
chemical leaks no crashes and certainly
nothing like what the video appeared to
show at the same time there were missing
persons reports being filed all across
the country in every area with a
thriving public transportation system
not only were the occupants of the Los
Angeles train unaccounted for with no
wreckage or bodies to be found but
people were disappearing in train
stations in New York Boston Chicago
Washington DC and more a woman reported
her husband missing after he called her
to check in during his daily commute
home from work the train had kept going
for much longer than it ordinarily did
drifting off of its usual route he told
her that something was wrong that he had
a terrible feeling of for boing and then
the call cut off he never made it home
for dinner a young woman was on her way
to start an internship at a prestigious
New York City magazine but never arrived
for her first meeting when her wouldbe
boss reached out to the girl's roommate
all he knew was that she had planned to
take the train to work that morning a
private detective trailing a man's wife
for him looking for evidence of an
affair lost track of her when she
stepped onto a train downtown he took
the next train hoping to catch her at
what he assumed would be her stop but
she never got off he wasn't able to
track her down down and had to give her
suspicious husband the news that his
wife had somehow vanished Into Thin Air
it wasn't just one or two people every
so often either entire train cars of
people were just disappearing never to
be seen again no matter how hard anyone
tried they could not find any answers no
logical explanation for what could have
happened fortunately the video
circulated so widely that it made it
onto the feed of an SCP Foundation
employee who was idly scrolling during a
bathroom break he was so shocked by what
he saw that he almost forgot to pull up
his pants before running out into the
Hall fortunately he did remember and
rushed to his supervisor's office fully
clothed after determining that the video
was not a hoax or some kind of viral
marketing stunt intended to sell a new
brand of spicy chips the SCP Foundation
decided to launch a formal investigation
into anomalous activity involving trains
and subway systems around the country
task forces were set up in every major
city and field re Searchers were
assigned to take the train all day every
day as much as possible as they did they
would maintain communication with the
head of their task force would monitor
their findings via hidden cameras and
microphones a week passed without
incident and the foundation was starting
to wonder if somehow the Los Angeles
video had been fak when the Chicago task
force made a harrowing Discovery officer
Jamie Bower was assigned to monitor the
trains on Chicago's Blue Line taking the
train throughout the day and keeping an
eye out for suspicious or potentially
anomalous Activity one week in and he
pretty much had it down to a basic
routine he would grab breakfast hop on
the train and enjoy his coffee and meal
while reading a book and writing the
train to its last stop then he'd pick up
lunch and do the same thing all over
again he'd have dinner and repeat it
wasn't too exciting but then again
excitement in this case probably meant
Horrors Beyond his comprehension so he
was perfectly fine with traversing the
city in a subway car and catching up on
the backlog of murder mysteries he'd
been meaning to read it was Monday
afternoon he'd picked up a slice of deep
dish pizza excited to try it for the
first time and walked down into the
metro station as he took his first bite
can you try not to chew into your
microphone please it's gross Dr Susan
Shephard the head of the Chicago task
force spoke into Jim's earpiece you got
it boss he said his mouth full thanks
see anything unusual today she asked you
tell me you can see the video feed right
he took by chewing as quietly as he
could sure but you're on the ground just
keep an eye out okay be careful remember
to draw your weapon if something go
south don't just disappear into your
book and forget to keep your wits about
you Dr Shephard sighed yep getting on
the train now not going to talk much so
these folks don't think I'm nuts jimie
waited for the doors to open and just
for a moment noticed that they seem to
stick just a little this time nothing to
be too worried about though everything
looked normal just as it had on every
other ride he'd taken he could feel the
Agatha chrisy book calling to him from
inside of his tote bag and he wanted to
crack it open and see what Clues heru P
had come across but Dr Shepard was right
he'd been slacking off he needed to pay
attention to his surroundings so he did
just that he watched as the train car
steadily filled up with passengers
college students with bags full of books
and exhausted Expressions middle-aged
people in business attire tourists
wearing souvenir baseball caps and
snapping pictures of everything in sight
before too long the train was completely
packed and Jamie could barely move
without bumping elbows with someone it
was a little claustrophobic but that was
public transportation Jaimie leaned back
in his seat pulled his book out and
focused on the comforting Rumble of the
engine the Rhythm Of The Wheels On The
Tracks suddenly without warning the
train screeched to a stop they were in
the middle of a tunnel Jamie assumed
from the darkness that flank them out
the window on either side wait was it
dark or had the window just disappeared
he squinted through the Blackness and
tried to see what was outside but he
couldn't make sense of his surroundings
all around the other passengers were
becoming Restless nervous some were
calling for help others were just
complaining doc you seeing this Jamie
hissed into the microphone I don't see a
thing Dr Shephard replied are you all
right fine the Train's just stalled I
don't know where or what's wrong with it
Jamie began feeling along the walls of
the train looking for doors huh that's
weird
what well the crack in the doors when
they come together should be right here
but it's all smooth no gaps or anything
like it's all one thing and it feels
strange like he cut himself off as his
stomach dropped a sudden Rush of fear
flooding his senses like what Dr
Shephard pressed like it's alive Jamie
said shakely Campbell what's happening
in there Dr Shephard began taking
Furious notes on her end I don't know
it's so dark everyone's scared I'm
scared I don't think this is a train I
don't know what it is but it's nothing
nothing good as Jamie felt around he
smelled something sour foul and sharp in
his nose he heard liquid splashing onto
the ground the sound of something
sizzling and then people started to
scream as he felt along the wall
something dripped onto his hand and then
it started to burn he cried out in agony
as whatever had dripped onto him ate
away at the skin dissolving his hand bit
by bit what is it Dr Shephard's voice
shook as she heard the pain in Jim's
voice some kind of acid oh God it's
everywhere it's on the walls floors it
just keeps coming he trailed off oh God
oh God we're in his stomach whatever
this thing is it's eating us Camp you
need to get out of there right now Dr
sheeper ordered draw your weapon
whatever you need to do just get out
Jamie pulled out his weapon and started
firing at the place where the do should
be but the bullets bounced off uselessly
as if the fleshy material was the side
of a tank he fired until there was no
more ammunition left and then he just
kept squeezing the trigger some more out
of pure survival Instinct but all it got
him was a useless click and the
certainty that the one thing he had
brought with him in case of emergency
was completely useless all the while the
acid was creeping higher dripping from
every surface filling the train car
until it swallowed the cries for help
and the screams of fear and Agony all Dr
Shepard could do was listen helpless as
Jamie and the rest of the passengers
were digested inside of the massive
stomach what happened to officer Jamie
Campbell was tragic but it provided
important information that the
foundation would likely never have
gotten otherwise they now knew a few key
things about this new anomaly it was
some kind of living thing able to
disguise itself as a train it was
resilient to bullets and firearms and it
was hiding in plain sight in order to
hunt human beings they had found the
culprit for the rash of mysterious
disappearances and it was a race of
unidentified creatures capable of taking
on the shape of a common underground
train the new found information quickly
circulated throughout the foundation
making its way to the various task
forces assigned to operation Metro as it
had been unofficially nicknamed task
force members were no longer instructed
to board trains instead they would slip
hidden cameras onto as many train cars
as they possibly could each outfitted
with a tracking device then the
foundation could remotely monitor the
trains for any potential signs of the
mysterious creatures looking for
Impostors masquerading as trains without
unnecessarily losing any more operative
in action now as for what they would do
once they found one of these massive
creatures was still uncertain but at
least they had somewhere to start the
SCP Foundation tried and failed to
contain several instances of the
carnivorous species before they finally
got it right they attempted to freeze
the inside of one train with liquid
nitrogen hoping to incapacitate the
creature before it could feed defend
itself or Escape custody the extreme
cold seemed to have no effect however
and the false train slammed its doors
shut at the first sign of discomfort
then sped away at high speed as it did
the task force members noticed that
though they could hear the sound of
wheels on the tracks they could see legs
jutting out of the bottom of the
creature scuttling along the ground next
they attempted to take out the
creature's legs and render it immobile
so that it could be subdued the legs
were resilient to external damage
becoming hard as a rock whenever any
weapon blade or other Implement made
contact with them one Task Force member
tried to physically hold some of the
legs in place but they shifted their
shape becoming appendages resembling
tentacles and threw the man out of the
way before the false train hurried out
of the tunnel and out of sight they were
then able to track down a predatory
train just after a feeding when it was
slightly sluggish after a large meal
they pumped an aerosolized poison into
the Train's interior the belly of the
Beast potent enough to take out a
dinosaur and were relieved to find that
the creature was unable to flee
unfortunately though they were able to
subdue the creature they killed it in
the the process at first they assumed it
was just inactive but it never resumed
activity again it was just like an
ordinary train car almost when the
interior was touched it felt warm and
slightly pliable less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh the longer
the creature was still the more the
windows on the side stopped looking like
Windows and started looking like wide
glassy eyes the front of the train
became a gaping maw the silhouette of
the conductor inside revealed as an
extension of the creature's body
resembling a tongue survivors and
Witnesses were given an amnestic to
remove any memories of the supposed
killer trains running under their city
and the foundation prepared to bring the
dead specimen in for further study a
cover story was used involving massive
repairs to the train system and while
the tunnels were closed off they managed
to remove the creature and transport it
to a nearby Foundation containment site
there it was given one of the most
extensive autopsies in Foundation
history and the first one one conducted
largely from inside the subject the
autopsy provided a more in-depth look at
the nature of the bizarre creature and
its curious nature the creature
nicknamed the train eater referring to
its preferred disguise and favorite
activity was one of an apparent species
of carnivorous predators that use
shape-shifting and an advanced form of
aggressive mimicry to prey on commuters
tourists and anyone else in need of a
ride from one place to the next it would
mimic the shape feel and sound of a
train welcoming unassuming victims into
its stomach and once it was completely
full and able to efficiently feed it
would release an incredibly potent
stomach acid into the compartment and
quickly dissolve everything inside the
creature was highly adaptable able to
harden parts of its body at will and
display extreme resilience to weapons of
any kind due to this nearly impenetrable
flesh victims trapped inside would be
unable to force their way out as the
research staff turned in their autopsy y
results and official report there was a
sense of unease in the air as everyone
wondered how many of these things are
out there which innocent trip to work
might be their last and how on Earth
could they hope to contain something
that could exist in endless numbers
something so expert at hiding in plain
sight there was no realistic way to
bring all these creatures into custody
and so they would have to neutralize as
many as possible without being detected
Foundation operatives embedded in
various city and state governments
introduced new measures to renovate
public transportation systems including
new sanitation protocols as part of
these protocols all trains would be
sprayed with a high strength
disinfectant before they could be
certified for use in reality this
disinfectant would be the same poison
used to take down the first train eater
the foundation studied once any and all
potent threats had been rendered
harmless trains that were found to be
formly living would be converted into
fully functioning trains and allowed to
run run as normal in order to avoid
unnecessary interruptions to the public
in addition to these containment
measures the foundation monitors all
social media for mentions of unusual
activity on trains or mentions of any
more missing persons lost at Metro
stations the original Los Angeles video
that started it all was scrubbed from
the internet entirely so by all means
take advantage of your local public
transportation options but remain
Vigilant and keep your wits about you
and remember next time you travel by
train if you see something say something
more specifically if you see something
unusual on a train if it looks a little
different than it did yesterday if it
sounds don't seem quite right make sure
to let everyone around you know that it
is not safe to be here and quickly make
your way to the exit then maybe walk to
your destination instead it might make
you a little bit late but hey better
late than dinner we all have fond
memories of the playground hours upon
hours spent in Blissful childhood
abandon racing around the local park
climbing the monkey bars and seeing if
you could get even higher on the swings
than your best friend and then of course
there's the slide who doesn't love a
slide only you and the force of gravity
pulling you down through a straight or
spiral tube those few seconds of
excitement that Rush of not knowing
whether you'll come out the other end of
the slide or not that's enough of a
thrill for any kid of course you would
always come tumbling out of the mouth of
the slide every time at worst with an
odd but innocent friction burn on your
leg or arm but what if one day you
didn't come out of the other end or
Worse what if the place at the end of
the slide wasn't the world you left
behind when you slid through the
entrance it doesn't seem all that likely
to happen right well you've obviously
never taken a trip down SCP
1562 better known known as the tunnel
slide as its moniker suggests SCP 1562
is a slide or it at least appears to be
an ordinary tunnel slide you know the
kind that you would easily find at any
kids park jungle gym or indoor play area
just over 2 m high and almost 3 and 1/2
M long and for the most part it is a
completely normal slide if you were to
just sit in it and glide down it feet
first nothing would happen then again if
SCP 1562 was an ordinary everyday piece
of a playground then the SCP Foundation
would not have such a vested interest in
it they definitely wouldn't be keeping
it locked up in quarantine secured in
Testing Lab 46- V of site 24 and if any
foundation agents ask you didn't hear
that from us by the way the door to the
lab is kept locked at all times no
member of personnel is even allowed near
the slide unless granted special
clearance to do so by Foundation
researcher Dr Carver so what is it that
makes this thing so special well for one
SC SCP 1562 was first recovered by the
foundation from a defunct abandoned
playground the location of this
playground has been redacted but it was
known to be on the outskirts of a town
where a number of young children had
been reported missing does SCP 1562
contain some sort of clue as to where
these children were taken perhaps some
piece of forensic evidence left behind
by a child snatching anomaly From
Another Dimension not quite SCP 1562 is
the thing that took those children you
see the slides anomalous properties
require very specific circumstances in
order to activate like we mentioned
earlier if you were just sitting on your
butt while you were sliding down it you
would Escape unscathed laying flat on
your back that is also a safe option
even flailing yourself about spinning
and rolling and waving your arms
changing position on the way down would
mean that nothing anomalous would appear
to happen however if someone enters SCP
1562 and travels down in head first
laying on their stomach with their arms
tucked at their side almost in a plank
position then that is when strange
things start to happen that is when a
person finds out what happened to those
missing children only about 15 cm from
the opening of the slide a person
sliding down on their front head first
With Arms by their sides will disappear
right before exiting SCP
1562 in an instant they will simply be
gone no longer in the slide or even
relocated to anywhere nearby to make
matters worse every single person that
this has happened to has never been
found again they literally have vanished
off the face of the Earth unfortunately
there isn't much that can be done to
prevent this during testing the
foundation quickly learned that
tethering a safety line to a subject
does little to stop them from
disappearing they cannot be pulled back
from wherever it is that the slide sends
them the Rope they are attached to is
simply cut and goes slack from the
moment that a person is taken by the
slide now that sounds like the whole
story right children are going missing
and the foundation learns it's because
of SCP
1562 some kind of interdimensional
portal within a playground slide so they
acquire the slide take it away and keep
it locked up securely where it can't
cause any disappearances end of story
except that's not quite the end no the
one thing it's still possible to do once
someone has disappeared down the slide
is to stay in contact with them the SCP
Foundation has expended a number of test
subjects by sending them sliding down
SCP 1562 just to learn what's on the
other side just where does the slide
take them luckily tests like this are
precisely what the foundation has
d-class Personnel for so so what
happened when the foundation sent some
DCL classes on a one-way joy ride down
the slide well one test involved a
d-class designated
d2445 who disappeared into SCP 1562 but
was given a two-way radio to communicate
directly with Dr derrs one of the
research staff d2445 reported that he
felt himself in a small cramped tunnel
and quickly requested to be let back out
Dr jarretts had neglected to tell d2445
that was impossible and that no one ever
came back from inside the slide while it
was too dark to see anything The
Prisoner described still being laid on
his front but feeling like there were
rocks or dirt surrounding him on all
sides realizing that he barely had
enough room to move or even lift his
head
d2445 again requested to be let out of
SCP
1562 as the unfortunate d-class grew
increasingly more unsettled by the
movement restricting environment Dr
darrett revealed that the lifeline
tethering D2 2445 back to the foundation
had been severed upon their
disappearance into the slide panicking
d2445 managed to move forward slightly
and realized that his head had hit
something a shoe a tiny child's shoe
communication with d2445 was called to a
halt and the foundation's researchers
discussed possible ways that they could
retrieve the prisoner although most of
them probably knew at this point that
this task was likely impossible this
test may have taken place before before
the foundation realized that return from
SCP 1562 was impossible the plan was
that another d-class would be sent into
the slide once again they would be
attached to a tether line and be
carrying video and audio recording
equipment along with a GPS tracker and a
headlamp reaching out to d2445 Dr
darrett relayed this plan to him d2445
immediately begged to be set free from
SCP 1562 as the doctor attempted to calm
him down but to little a fact something
had scared him truly terrified him a
sound coming from somewhere within the
tunnel it it started talking d2445
claimed when Dr darrett asked for
clarity the d-class replied saying that
a little boy had tried to speak to him
but that the child had made little sense
he just kept asking where he was and I
told him I didn't know but I don't think
he was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm when asked if this child
had moved at all d2445 said that he was
unsure he started screaming and I told
him to shut up but he just kept
screaming and crying and asking for his
mommy and then he finally stopped and
shortly after that you contacted me
again please get me out now Dr derrett
tried to reassure the man to little aail
and communication with d2445 was cut off
after he claimed something was wrong
with his chest
shortly after the foundation lost
communication with
d2445 another member of d-class was sent
into the slide after him this subject
referred to officially as D 8600 had
been specifically selected for this task
thanks to his small stature Dr darrett
and the other Foundation researchers
testing SCP 1562 believed that the man's
thinner body type would allow D 8600 to
better navigate the tunnel that the
slides seemed to transport people to and
you can probably guessed what happened
next just like all the others that had
been sent down the slide d86 was trapped
his Lifeline was cut the moment that he
vanished inside the tunnel slide on top
of this the GPS tracker that this
thinner d-class had been issued with
seemed to not be working properly its
signal could not be correctly traced and
without an accurate fix there was no way
to determine the location to which SCP
1562 was transporting its victims if it
was even in this universe Additionally
the video feed from the camera d86 was
carrying also failed to connect with
only audio from his radio being
recovered by the research team
contacting
d86 Dr darrett was informed by this new
d-class that his headlamp had stopped
working the second he had arrived in the
same cave or tunnel as earlier test
subjects before long by shimmying
through the area on his arms d86 bumped
into a foot believed to be belonging to
d25
445 while he could barely see anything
d86 could hear
d2445 voice and this was being faintly
picked up via His Radio however as he
and Dr darrett tried to talk to the
first prisoner his words began to sound
all too familiar I don't know some sort
of very small tunnel it's really cramped
can you get me out now followed by no
it's it's too dark I can't see anything
and I'm stuck it was all just a
recording from what
d2445 had said when he first arrived
after SCP 1562 had sent him into the
tunnel d86 did not realized this at
first and attempted to help his fellow
prisoner hoping to pull him out of
wherever they were trapped Dr darrett
tried desperately to explain that d2445
was just repeating his half of an
earlier conversation but D 8600 hardly
noticed that was the case he gripped the
other DCL class's ankles and told the
doctor to pull them out of the tunnel
the doctor revealed that once again the
tether line had been severed but D 8600
refused to believe that escape was
impossible he tried to worm his way back
the way he had come leaving d2445 still
repeating his words from earlier he just
kept asking me where he was and I told
him I didn't know but I don't think he
was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm I don't think so he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he kept just screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy then and he finally
stopped and shortly after that you
contacted me again please get me out now
please hurry my chest is really starting
to hurt after yelling at him to stop
talking multiple times d86 noted that
d2445 had finally gone quiet the d-class
also remarked that the air was starting
to taste stale and hoped that there
would be enough oxygen for him to get
back then just like his predecessor
communication with d86 came to an abrupt
stop Dr darrett was no longer able to
reach him on the radio there was nothing
but static the foundation was unable to
reestablish contact with either of the
two D class Personnel lost inside SCP
1562 and any future testing of the
tunnel slide was suspended to this day
none of us know what exactly happened to
the victims of the tunnel slide where
were they taken what had taken them what
was making the prior victims repeat
their ominous words as horror author
Stephen King once put it it it's the
unanswered questions that stays with us
the longest but the next time you decide
to Thrill your inner child by taking a
jean to your local Kitty Park you may
just find out for yourself being a video
archist for the SCP Foundation is one of
the easiest jobs in the entire
organization you're responsible for
viewing every tape found in the field
every interview with an anomaly and
every event log recorded by a mobile
Task Force if something passes your desk
that means the found is going to want
its contents viewed transcribed and the
original Source footage stored for
preservation compared to the doctors
working tirelessly to push their
research to the boundaries of understood
science and field agents risking their
lives elsewhere your job of lounging in
an airconditioned room sitting at a
computer and watching videos all day
seems pretty appealing at least on paper
it does when you take into account just
what it is you'll be transcribing the
Grim reties present present in all
Foundation careers starts to emerge in
your deceptively cushy office gig it's
no secret that the foundation's visual
logs describe unspeakable Horrors within
disgusting body alterations gory details
and terrifying imagery are Mainstays of
foundation files most are never
conscious of the fact that every log
that's been written out had to have been
viewed by someone in the first place
those blank redacted areas where your
imagination has to fill in the detail
somewhere someone in the foundation had
to describe that sensitive information
in the first place that Gruesome Kill in
the taskforce report the visual
archivist saw the footage before they
wrote it out sure your job might be to
watch the foundation's home movies all
day but due to the sheer amount of
visual materials the foundation needs to
transcribe and catalog you'll be on
average seeing far more Horrors than the
typical researcher or Task Force member
instead of being assigned to one or two
projects at a time you'll witness an
infinite slew of footage from across the
foundation's history you'll just be
viewing all of the horror from a
distance behind a screen after the fact
but you don't need to be told that
you're a professional hardboiled
grizzled veteran of the foundation you
watch hours of footage a day transcribe
it archive it and send it out to be
inserted in the various articles and
files in the foundation database you've
lived through countless Task Force
missions observed endless testing logs
and seen everything from unimaginable
entities to the bloodiest events ever
taken place it used to keep you up at
night but at this point you're
desensitized to almost anything the
world can throw at you maybe that's why
you were the foundation's latest choice
to transcribe the footage recovered from
the site of SCP
6670 you'd heard the stories a series of
tapes the other archists were flat out
refusing to transcribe due to sheer
disgust and horror they'd been passed
down the line two or three times and now
they came to you in a box of literal VHS
tapes labeled with a strip of tape that
read SCP 6670 recovered media you didn't
doubt that whatever was on these was
intense since it was enough to get a few
Foundation archivists to pass something
that rarely happens but you were sure
they weren't anything you couldn't
handle you inspect the box for a manif
paper to see if you can gain any other
information about the tapes most of the
time the varying parts of the
foundation's research is kept heavily in
discernible from one another the right
hand never knows what the left is doing
so getting any further context to the
footage you're about to review is often
times necessary but the paper inserted
on top of the box doesn't reveal much it
reads footage recovered from the
discovery site of SCP
6670 containment site 86 Detro Detroit
Michigan that's about as much as you're
going to get but at least it's something
you take the tape that says first on it
and pop it into the VCR yeah you had to
dust off that old dinosaur just for this
the real anomaly is that it still works
after all these years the first tape is
overlaid with a title that takes up the
entirety of the screen happy birthday
Gemma 1988 it reads the camera pans to a
small infant laying down on a cushion
you can tell from the brief glimpses of
the background that the house is
dilapidated poorly held together not the
conditions a child should be raised in
but an unfortunate reality that some
face the baby stares at the camera
wiggling and making adorable baby noises
you wonder if this is Gemma the birthday
girl herself your thoughts are confirmed
by the camera holder who plays with and
tickles Gemma celebrating her birthday
the camera holder asked the baby to
smile for mommy which the little Gemma
gleefully does of course the one holding
the camera is gemma's Mother and the two
are celebrating her first birthday the
rest of the tape is ordinary with Gemma
and her mother playing and laughing
together her mother sings Happy Birthday
to her and the recording stops well that
wasn't so bad you think to yourself in
fact taking into account most of the
stuff that passes your desk that was
pretty good but that was only the first
tape you're intrinsically drawn to the
next one wondering how this could
possibly Inspire so much fear in the
others who watched it second tape The
Shot opens up with a woman dressed in a
slightly tattered sewn together formal
attire she's filming herself standing
before a mirror the title reads job
interview practice tape after the title
disappears she begins talking to herself
she reveals her name Melanie Jamie G
Parker and acts as if she's applying to
a job specifically to an internship at
the Walter media a broadcast company you
can tell from the sound of her voice
that this is gemma's Mother Melanie's
mock interview proceeds slowly she's
visibly apprehensive chokes over her
words and seems to be in great distress
Melanie mentions that she turned 18 the
other day and that she's interested in
applying for a job as a news reporter
still she can't get the words out
properly stuttering and hesitating she's
clearly distracted by something off
camera Midway through her rehearsal the
sound of high-pitched crying is heard
it's the baby Melanie assures Gemma that
she's coming and leans over to hit the
button to stop the recording before
rushing off to calm down the crying
child again nothing horrible you think
it's difficult to watch someone so young
struggle with the challenges of
motherhood but it hasn't made you lose
your lunch or anything you take out the
third tape pop it in and see what
happens next another title a letter to
my family cut this seems like it was
intended to be thrown out the picture
comes in showing a crying Melanie
sitting on the edge of her bed in a
white gown sniffling up her tears
Melanie delivers a message intended to
be viewed by her family you learn that
her relationship with them is unstable
and that Melanie has been on her own for
months potentially longer she musters
out an apology to her parents saying
that she's sorry about everything for a
party for stealing their money she
continues to cry but tells them that she
wants them to know that she's sorry and
that she loves them she addresses her
sister's caring attitude and her
mother's smile but is hesitant to
compliment her father she reveals that
she hasn't spoken to them in 2 years but
she can't go any longer she's barely
been able to afford basic necessities
and despite applying for as many jobs as
she could she hasn't landed one her
personal savings are almost depleted and
she can't sleep at night gemma's getting
bigger a lot bigger than any girl should
be at two she's rapidly outgrowing her
clothes and Melanie's unable to provide
her with the love and care that she
needs she's halfway through saying that
she wants her parents to take custody of
Gemma but she stops she can't get
herself to admit it she stares at the
camera shakes her head and begins
cursing Melanie's voice gets louder and
she vly defends her decision to keep
Gemma for herself she not subjecting
herself to her family who she clearly
despises Melanie continues to lash out
against her family saying that she's
tired of them and that they will never
find her and Gemma she's visibly shaking
her voice unstable melan's made her
decision gemma's staying with her she
makes a statement you should have seen
how happy Gemma and I were how nice life
is out here the sun's so much brighter
there's no no fighting no screaming no
crying I took my daughter and I left all
of you and I am happy in the background
gemma's crying is heard again from
another room Melanie drained looks in
the distance surprised to hear that
she's awake she wipes the tears from her
eyes and assures Gemma that her mother
will be right there she forgets to turn
the camera off and rushes out of the
room for the rest of the tape lasting
nearly 2 hours in duration Melanie calms
Gemma holding her and assuring her that
she's safe eventually the camera's
battery gives out and the recording
stops so far it's definitely upsetting
to see but you haven't encountered
anything anomalous yet maybe it's the
fourth tape that will shed some light on
what's going on here you put it in and
prepare for the worst this tape Cuts in
immediately without a title Gemma and
Melanie are playing together in
Melanie's bedroom what she said about
gemma's growth is two she's only two but
she stands at 4T tall with long and
disheveled blonde hair Gemma runs across
the bedroom making noises and pretending
to be an airplane Melanie for once
doesn't seem to be stressed though she
looks visibly tired the sound of a phone
ringing is heard in the background
Melanie immediately snaps out of her
happy attitude and runs off to answer it
while she talks on the phone Gemma is
seen peering into a small hole in the
wall of the bedroom she then moves offc
screen while Melanie is talking on the
phone Gemma tries to get her mother's
attention when Melanie hangs up she
notices that she doesn't see her
daughter anywhere and begins frantically
searching Gemma answers her voice coming
from inside the hole in the wall Melanie
tries to go her child from outside the
wall but Gemma doesn't listen eventually
she hears a loud snap and then a scream
Melanie panics moving her head into the
hole Gemma cries screaming that she's in
pain and that she hurts something
Melanie tells tells her that she'll get
help and desperately tries not to panic
she runs off screen and for 15 minutes
all that's heard is Gemma crying Melanie
returns with a young man who would later
be identified as her neighbor John Bates
he carries a rope Melanie directs bits
to a hole in the wall the two are
clearly familiar with one another and
Melanie assures Gemma that Mr JN is
going to help her out of the hole Bates
kneels on the floor and inserts his head
into the wall feeding the rope inside
the hole on the count of three they tell
Gemma to grab the rope and they'll pull
seconds pass without a response and
suddenly Bates feels a tug she's
grabbing the Rope Melanie and Bates pull
together hoping to lift Gemma out of
wherever she fell but the girl won't
move she continues to cry saying that
she's stuck and neither Bates nor
Melanie can get her to budge Melanie who
is now crying assures Gemma that they'll
get her out while Bates is more
reluctant Bates tells her that they
aren't going to be able ble to get her
out by themselves and the two begin to
argue loudly they agree to call the fire
department after all they're specialized
in getting people out of confined spaces
Bates tries calling but the lines are
full meanwhile Melanie continues to lose
hope Bates insists that they have to
call 911 but Melanie knows that she
doesn't have enough to cover medical
costs and if they discover the living
conditions that gemma's been in they'll
surely take her child away the two
continue to argue bit suggest s that
Melanie phones her family which is the
ultimate breaking point for her from off
screen you can hear a struggle the sound
of a cupboard opening and then baits
hitting the floor 30 minutes of silence
follow when Melanie returns she's caked
in dirt grease and blood what happened
was evident Melanie sticks her head
inside the hole in the wall and assures
GMA that her mother will take care of
her the next tape pulls you in the title
displays happy birthday Gemma
1991 you recognize that the video is
being taken from inside the wall there's
a small lava lamp and a cupcake with a
candle in front of Gemma who lays prone
on the ground she's more pale than
before and looks to be about 5 ft tall
now and her shoulders Encompass the
length of the space from behind the
camera Melanie sings to her and Gemma
blows out the candle the recording Stops
Another tape happy birthday Gemma
1993 gemma's looking visibly ill her
eyes droop she smiles tiredly and her
body seems to be larger than the space
it's confined to a cake sits in front of
her with five candles Melanie sings to
her again the 1997 birthday tape is even
worse Gemma is about 7 ft tall and her
face encompasses the entire hole with no
discernable head Melanie sings to Gemma
who just want wants to eat her cake the
sound of gemma's Bones clinking and
cracking as her body contorts to the
tight space is heard the next tape is
unlabeled but the foundation determined
it to be recorded around 2001 Melanie
sits outside the door to her bedroom
sobbing her bedroom is entirely
inaccessible behind the door the
cracking of Bones is heard throughout
the house she's singing happy birthday
to Gemma who is unseen gemma's voice can
be heard begging for food and another
crack this time from the ceiling dust
Falls from above the house is giving out
Gemma screams that she's in pain and
that she doesn't want to fall the
cracking gets louder and before Melanie
can finish singing she's taken back by
the horror of the situation Gemma begs
for her mother to help her and that her
back hurts the ceiling's about to give
out any second and suddenly it does the
camera tips showing a ceiling full of
cracks which gives out over the next few
seconds Melanie screams that she'll
catch Gemma but she is simply too big
her form is revealed a block of barely
human skin and tissue shaped into a
square Mass due to being confined to the
walls for years you can't tell that the
entity before you is still human and
most of all an injured scared child
gemma's anomalous growth when confined
to such a small space over a long period
of time resulted in this Gemma falls to
the floor brushing Melanie in the
process for the remaining 4 hours of the
tape Gemma sifts and struggles all while
crying out for her mother the tape stops
disturbed by the content you know you're
going to feel sick transcribing these
tapes you check the coresponding
database file for SCP 6670 in hopes you
can access it thankfully it's within
your clearance and all is illuminated
when you read what's already there SCP
6670 is Gemma described as a large
amorphous entity made of Flesh tissue
and contorted bones SCP 6670 is confined
to a small house in Detroit Michigan
where it's been contained on site with a
concrete Wall constructed around the
home SCP 6670 was discovered following
the recording of the tape when passers
by outside the house described the
structure as breathing after which
containment measures were implemented
and research began the only access point
to SCP 6 670 is through the doorway
outside the bedroom as most of the
House's structure is either destroyed or
taken up by SCP 6670 Mass x-ray scans
revealed that SCP 6670 spine is
extremely contorted and is assumed to
have grown along the dimensions of the
home with puberty assumed to have
accelerated the growing process SCP 6670
is largely immobile and is believed to
be hibernating its intelligence seems to
be roughly equ to a small child inside
the home the tapes were found and the
file describes them as a waiting
transcription which is your job beneath
the section intended for your work is an
event log transcribed by Personnel
working on site with SCP
6670 the entity after remaining a mobile
for so long had eventually moved the log
read as follows the entity rolled in
front of the camera where its mouth
could be seen it's surrounded by several
Str rings of Rotting Flesh and caked
with blood the teeth are rotten
consistent with typical patterns of
tooth decay a clump of black hair clings
to the side of its lower lip SCP 6670 is
heard speaking the camera registers the
sound as similar to Mama I'm hungry its
voice is that of a young girl you're
taken back by the graphic bodily
alteration described when the
realization hits you that you're going
to have to watch these tapes multiple
times over to ensure proper
transcription but then one other thing
stands out a clump of black hair on SCP
667s lip but Gemma had blonde hair and
then it hits you you know that you'll be
in for many sleepless nights after this
is all said and done ask anyone that has
been through it and they'll all tell you
the same that moving home is maybe one
of the most stressful things that a
normal person can ever experience it's a
logistical nightmare right from the
start the moment you talk to a realtor
about being interested in selling your
current house and buying another
everything goes downhill from there
after that moment an avalanche of things
comes hurdling towards you finding a
place you like making an offer letting
people look around your house waiting
for them to make a counter offer
exchanging contracts and that's before
you even have thought about packing and
as Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realator the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possessions and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian ER of feel to it all
beautifully carved and varnished
Woodwork and creaky old floorboards but
in more of an elegant refined sort of
way rather than a creepier one that's
not to say Milo's new place wasn't
without its more unsettling elements
aside from being big spacious and easy
to imagine as being haunted the
creepiest thing about the house aside
from its frighteningly low price was the
story of what happened to the previous
owners obviously you know that legally
we have to disclose whether or not
anyone died on this property the
realator had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realator instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
client's nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realator ended her sentence with
a forced snorting laugh but rained it
back in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here that Shaws they were apparently
very quiet reclusive kept to themselves
a lot I'm sure you know the type Milo
couldn't help but notice she shot him a
look as she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay okay and no one
had any bad mishaps in the house you
know how old folks can be such a worry
when they get to that age yeah totally
Milo interjected a where the realator
was stalling he repeated so what
actually happened to them well that's
the thing she Shrugged Nobody Knows the
full story one day the neighbors across
the street noticed they hadn't seen Mr
and Mrs Shaw for quite a while so
naturally they came on over here to see
if they were in and the last thing they
wanted was to assume everything was
tunky Dory here I mean hey better save
them sorry right but once they got
inside they couldn't find either of them
Mr and Mrs Shaw were just gone vanished
Without a Trace most people on the
street thought they had just sold the
place kept it quiet and moved away
retired to somewhere nice and exotic Oh
well that sounds nice I suppose Milo
replied relieved to hear that there
hadn't been any brutal unsolved murders
in the house and that it most likely
wasn't haunted that's just what the
neighbors think anyway the realator
continued of course they hadn't sold the
house they just left it when my firm
came in to repossess the place it had
all their belongings in it some might
even still be laying around here anyway
did you want to have a look at that
contract well strictly speaking Milo was
the only human living in his new house
he was never fully alone he had arrived
with his two closest friends a pair of
pets he had adopted while living in his
old house one was a hamster by the name
of donut named after his round little
body and the golden brown shade of his
fur had reminded Milo of the glaze
sugary baked treat the other was Pixel a
bearded dragon with a pattern on his
scales that resembled some kind of
mosaic art the first order of business
Milo had decided was before even
unpacking he needed to make sure his
scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the shaw still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes or a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of course
the bigger clue was the huge handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some
of the remaining boxes in the Attic he
wasn't exactly well versed in knitwear
but he could appreciate the craft behind
this soft blanket it clearly had a lot
of time and effort put into making it
painstakingly knitting each and every
individual thread looping it around a
pair of Steel needles and eventually
after hours of wearing out shaking bony
fingers produced something that actually
looked quite nice even though the idea
of sitting and knitting a blanket might
have been one of the most boring uses of
time Milo could imagine he still had to
admit he was surprised that the Shaws
had left this particular piece of
bedding behind it seemed like it would
be pretty comfy to sleep under it might
help keep a person warm at night now
that the colder seasons were approaching
what's more was that the blanket was
clean almost like it had been freshly
washed there was no old person smell on
it no dirt or discoloration not a stain
and it hadn't even accumulated any dust
in its fibers in in fact he noticed that
there was hardly any dust at all up in
the attic despite the house being empty
for so long he assumed the realators had
hired someone As a caretaker while they
found a buyer for the place and they had
kept the place clean after all what
other conclusion could they have
possibly drawn it's not as if something
had eaten all the dust that would be
absurd he'd have a sort through of the
Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell some
of it off at a local yard sale or give
it to a thrift store but that blanket
might come in handy when it started
snowing so Milo had half a mind to keep
it now part of what makes moving home
such a stressful life experience isn't
just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions bury deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the lad of his two
Pets the bearded dragon usually spent
most of his days in a spacious glass
tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most days seemed to be filled with
more energy than Milo was as a result he
let the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the reals had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturb disturbance that
emanated from some hidden corner of the
building only seemed to get a thousand
times louder when the sun went down at
nighttime every squeaky floorboard or
random noise of the house settling was
nearly deafening enough to pull Milo
right out of what little Restless sleep
he was getting the worst part about it
was though he couldn't help it it made
him feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shaws showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night night Milo was
seeing the old couple in every bad dream
he had both their faces were locked in
those same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail on the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
fur hamster then the crates that still
littered the place grabbing the leftover
items that the shots had forgotten to
take with them before they vanished Milo
moved those boxes out into the shed he
knew he was probably reaching that it
was hard likely to make even the
slightest difference to his sleeping but
maybe keeping their stuff away from him
would keep the old couple out of his
head the only thing he kept in the house
was the blanket there was no use letting
it go to waste especially knowing that
the boiler was on the blink and it would
be cold soon he rolled it up and left it
on his bed leaving his more mobile pet
in the same room before heading out to
see the doctor when Milo got back a
bottle of prescription sleeping pills in
his pocket he couldn't help but notice
his room seemed different the blanket
looked like it had fallen off the bed
and onto the floor floor for one but
more worryingly Donut's plastic travel
ball had been split open laying in
pieces on the ground with its furly
little occupant nowhere to be seen over
the next few hours Milo searched every
corner of the house calling out to his
hamster trying to lure it back with more
morsels of food but donut didn't seem to
be anywhere he wasn't even underneath
the knitted blanket still there was no
sign as worry set in Milo hurly checked
pixel's cage to see if he was gone too
but the lizard was relaxing as lethargic
as ever completely unfazed by what was
going on it certainly seemed that when
it rained it really poured in this new
house just as he was searching for his
missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for The house's boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge ironcast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got home going
to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back back in bed as night
had fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too and not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his
hands should be were what finally pulled
him out of the dream and into the
nightmare through the dark and his
cloudy vision Milo could see a wide
gaping ma filled with teeth the feeling
of being crushed was still surrounding
him and despite kicking his legs and
trying to free himself from confinement
it didn't stop squeezing him tighter his
Panic was already making it harder to
catch his breath but now he could barely
fill his lungs enough to scream for help
not that any anyone was around to hear
him but it was the side of his arm that
chilled Milo's blood it wasn't there
anymore part of it just above the elbow
was just gone his hand fingers every
internal bone and muscle had been
reduced to a bloody mess a slurry of red
melting and coming apart it was runny
little more than a liquid resembling the
consistency of sand when it's underwater
and becomes sludge most of his flesh was
liquefied going further up his arm and
as the blanket pulled its prey into its
mouth until Milo was no more not a trace
of him left just like the previous
owners little did Milo or the Shaw and
donut before him know but he'd been the
victim of a creature that was part of a
rather unique species well they will
often vary in size shape pattern and
other aspects of their appearance SCP
799 always seemed to be ordinary items
of knitted bedwear at least at first
they retain heat like a normal blanket
wood and are soft to the touch and for
the most most part don't seem directly
harmful and usually they aren't SCP 799
are incapable of much movement instead
laying still a lot of time not unlike a
certain bearded dragon that just lost
its owner they also don't seem to
require much in the way of food
extracting what little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouth in the fibers however
this changes if an SCP 799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
will they possess this biological trait
themselves SCP 799 don't seem to regard
coldblooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles instead SCP 799
will metamorphose into a more predatory
form in order to consume any warm BL
blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feet itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live now go and check out SCP 3032 and
then it was an angry spider for more
warnings about everyday objects that can
seem harmless at first but will quickly
turn deadly when you least expect it and
after that if you're in the market for a
piece of anomalous Furniture that's
still soft and cozy like the blanket but
nowhere near as dangerous then SCP 3832
surprise pillow fight might be just what
you need